learn how to use figma variants to
design a scalable mobile app from amit
who is a very experienced ux designer
variants can streamline your front-end
design process by allowing you to group
and organize similar components into a
single container hey guys and welcome to
a brand new tutorial now in this
tutorial what i'm going to share with
you is actually how to build a scalable
mobile application step by step on figma
now this course is actually done in a
two separate stages in the first stage
what you are going to learn is basically
going to be an overview we are going to
learn some of the figma's best tools
such as how to use frames how to use the
auto layout how to use components so
that you can build scalable apps on your
own but all these three concepts will
tie into my favorite components which is
variance you will learn how to use figma
variants so that you can create scalable
applications that are also flexible that
have a different variations for your
elements so that your designs will not
look just like a standard app
now what also matters in this course is
that i also have added a homework a
practice file if you wish that i am
actually going to add to the description
of this video below so that you can take
it and practice the concepts you'll
learn to solidify and master it on your
own the homework has suggested solutions
attached already so don't worry we have
everything covered here and then after
we gave you the overview and maybe you
practiced the homework then you can do
the tutorial where we will build a
mobile app from scratch it's actually a
great long tutorial and i know you will
enjoy it and before we go any further if
you are new here my name is ahmed and
i'm a ui ux designer currently living in
canada waterloo and i will be your host
today and i will see you on the tutorial
but before we begin the tutorial and
give you an overview of what you are
going to learn
what i want to do first is that i want
to show you how to use the two figma
files i will add to the description to
this video below so that you can follow
along the tutorial but also get your
homework so that you can actually
practice what you learned so that you
can master the concepts easier
now once you go to the description and
click one of those links you will have
either the tutorial initial screens file
or you will have the homework file and
doesn't matter which file you are on
what i want you to do to actually have
the ability to edit these files is you
want to click on the drop down here and
you want to press duplicate your drafts
and let's go to the homework file and
let's do that let's say
drop down duplicate your drafts and now
that is actually saved and i want to
press open so now this project is
actually copied to my own account and
now i actually can edit it if you don't
follow this step you won't be able to
edit the file because
i will not give you an added access for
the master file you have to copy it on
your own so that you can actually edit
it on your own account
so once you are here one more thing
about the homework file before we go on
each homework file actually has an
exercise so each homework file has a
suggested solution
and it and in the main homework frame
what you have is that you have your
instructions and then you have four
different exercises each exercise
actually has
a solution where if you click on the
component here and press ctrl shift h
you can view it and then if you press
ctrl shift h again you can hide it that
is for windows for mac if i'm not wrong
it should be
command shift h to hide and show and
that is how you can compare and contrast
your solutions and again if you have any
questions whatsoever just comment on
this video and i will actually do my
best to help you
and let's go
all right so let's get cracking now what
you see right now in my window is the
end result of what we are going to
design today in this tutorial and what
you see is roughly 10 to 12 screens of a
activity app that is a mobile app where
you get to choose which city you are
visiting then you get to pick your
activity and you schedule it
and then you pay for it at the end so
that is going to be the main workflow
and
the goal for us though isn't just to
design this high fidelity mobile app the
goal is also to create it and design it
with various thing metals and the most
important being variants so that it is
much more easy
to make it scale later
and
that is what we are going to do today
and it's going to be amazing so make
sure you stick around till the end of
this video and let's get started now if
you like this tutorial and you want to
get better at ui ux design specifically
i have my own personal channel with my
name ahmed aferoglu where i post twice a
week videos on uiux design on how to get
better at figma how to get better at
communications how to get better at ui
ux design whether that is soft or hard
skills so you can actually become a
better uix designer you can also go to
the free code cam channel for this
tutorial where they actually post
all kinds of videos from development to
security to ui ux design so that if you
want to learn holistically all these new
technologies free code cam is actually
one of the best channels that i know
please make sure you subscribe to this
channel as well it's been amazing for me
to actually learn front-end development
and back-end development and i'm really
glad this channel exists
so before we actually began the process
of designing the high fidelity mobile
app and make sure that we are using
variants we have to cover our bases
now because i do not know what your base
level of skill is on figma whether that
is using its tools or features
i have to make sure we are going to
cover the basics of what we will use so
that you will be able to use the
variants that will help your app be much
more scalable and to do that i have to
actually show you how to use frame
auto layout component and variance on
figma
and
if you are new to this don't worry i'm
just going to show you in a second but
also if you want to solidify what you
learn if you feel uncomfortable still
after this
quick tutorial if you want to solidify
what you learn
in the description of this video there
is a homework link that you can go it
has suggested solutions already where
you can practice what you learned here
and that would solidify your knowledge
before you actually go on
to
do this whole design process from
beginning to end
so let's get started with framing and
also before i start if you look at the
bottom left corner i have the shortcuts
coming in i'm gonna actually move my
yep i'm gonna move my picture to the
right so on the left side you can
actually see
here
that i have the
key caster tool so that you can actually
see what i'm pressing when i'm doing
certain shortcuts and i would like to
apologize in advance the shift key is
buggy so it doesn't show make sure you
also hear listen to my voice for the
shortcut
so anytime i actually want to understand
how a certain feature of tool works i
basically try to use it in the most
simplest ui element possible so i do not
focus on what i'm designing but how i
will use the tool and the simplest ui
design element that i know and you guys
know is a button
so what i will do is now i will design a
button with a frame so i will
pick the f short key and i'm gonna move
my profile again there you go so i'm
gonna press on f as my short key here
and i'm gonna drag a frame
and i'm gonna set this twist to 128
pixels for width
and 48 pixels for height and right now
it does not have any fill color so if i
click on fill here
now it does and i'm going to pick a
grayish color and now we have something
like a background
and i'm gonna add to this frame a text
so i'm gonna click on the frame
press t
for the shortcut for text and i'm gonna
say login
now i'm gonna pick the auto wet so the
text doesn't stretch horizontally
and now what i want to do is i wanna
center it and having a frame basically
allows me to group elements that are
have to be in the same group visually so
for a button that would be your
background and that would also be your
label text for let's say an input field
input text field you might want to frame
your label you might want to frame your
placeholder and you might want to frame
your background all in just one single
frame
and it also gives you certain powers
such as
basically making the content very easy
to actually align so i can actually
center a line horizontally i'm
vertically in the right side here
and that works right now pretty good
now another power that the frames give
you on figma is they are a gateway to
actually creating more scalable ui
designs and the one way to actually make
your design much more scalable is to use
it with auto layout if you add the auto
layout portion to a frame and to do that
you have to click on
plus and i'm going to do that but i'm
just going to copy and paste this
so we have an example so on the left
side i will have a normal frame and on
the right side i will have a frame with
an auto layout
and boom so what this frame right now
has is this
auto layout basically lets us
dynamically stretch our button no matter
what the input that is one of the powers
it can give you and i'm gonna show you
what i mean so look at the left side the
left side is the button again with the
no auto layout functionality and i'm
just gonna write n n n n nnn and this
happens all the time you might have a
button with the label login but it might
also become submit or download and you
might want to use the same design and
you don't want to recreate it all the
time
and
for that reason auto layout kicks in
very well so if i do and and and n right
now you can see this button scales on
its own and it so what figma does is it
lets you pick the margins the paddings
around the element and you can specify
here let's say center let's do
24
24 and no matter the text size
this
button will scale horizontally even if
you increase the text size while keeping
the right
left
top button padding the same now is this
the only power of the auto layout
feature does it only let us design
buttons of course not another good way
for you to use it is instead of just
scaling horizontally
also vertically what you can do is you
can also use it to add spacing between
elements so you can actually use this
for more complex stuff for example let's
create a new card by pressing f
to create our card frame let's fill it
with white let's add a drop shadow with
effects here
and that's a very rough drop shadow but
that will do for now
and let's add a title
and let's get this to be 18 pixels let's
fold it out with ctrl b
and
let's just copy and paste it again here
and let's say loram epsom
basically let's have our text here
let's make this 16
and unbolt it okay so we have a title we
have a body
and we are inside this frame and one
thing you usually do is you really want
to make sure that there is a certain
spacing around your card but also
there's a certain spacing between
elements
so what you can do is if you add the
auto layout to your frame here
and instead of
horizontal direction which we chose for
buttons here
you can choose the vertical one and you
can also specify the
spacing between items meaning what's the
space gonna be between our title and
body text and let's pick that to be 12
pixels
and also we can add the margins of
16 pixel 16 pixel
16 pixel and you want to be around here
so what now happened is we have a left
margin of 16 top margin of 16 a margin
of 16 and right margin of 16 but the
spacing between our elements is 12
pixels
and this is very useful because what
this will lecture is
it will make it very easy to make your
designs consistent you won't have to
check the distance between each element
vertically
almost ever again if you
know how to master the auto layout
feature
now let's move on to components so you
have your frames and you have your
auto layouts
and let me zoom out a bit with shift
zero
so what is the value of components and
what is it and that's a very good
question and to do that i am gonna first
create another screen
and let's make that a iphone 13 mini
and
let's
what we are going to do is we are going
to copy this button again and paste it
just below here
so
you having a frame an auto layout makes
it scalable but you still have a problem
let's say we decide to use this button
i'm gonna control c to copy
and ctrl v to paste on this
iphone 13 screen which is a very empty
screen i know i'm like ah i always
forget to place this profile
in the right but okay
so we have this very boring screen what
can we do really
what can we do to basically show us the
problem that we might have what i will
now do is that
i want to basically
have the second screen of mobile screen
and that is also normal you usually will
have 30 to 50 and i want this to be
actually
let's say
login as well
but
during the design i realized that
i actually want this to
be blue color and let's make this blue
oh yep let's make this blue
so
i designed this color i designed the
color of this button again but you can
realize even though i copied and pasted
from this color this button
its color did not change and now picture
this let's say you have 50 mobile
screens and you realize your
color for your button is wrong and you
actually wanted blue instead of brown
and you have to go now so 50 other
screens and change the color each time
and that is a hassle and that takes so
much time
what components do is they actually
solve this problem specifically what
components do is
they let you create a master element and
to do that we have to first make this
button a component first
and the way to do that is
control
alt k on windows now this is a component
and what you can do is i'm going to
delete these buttons now
what you can do is to actually use a
component in the actual
app screens you have you go to assets
each component shows on the assets panel
here
and it basically lets you organize your
files and this becomes very handy it's a
drop down here so it becomes very handy
once you have multiple let's say types
of components and to fetch it you
basically drag the component you picked
and it's here
and you can also copy and paste like a
normal button
and it's here
and now
we realize that we actually want the
color of the
button to be blue how do we change it we
go to the master element
click
and we basically i'm going to move my
profile here a bit and we change its
color to blue
and then you realize all the other
buttons that actually were the children
of this master element also change so
this makes it very easy for you to make
changes yet it has a problem and
variants came to rescue for this problem
the problem is what if you want to use
the blue color
and the brown color so in 25 screens of
your apps you are using the color blue
in 30 of them you are using the color
brown
how
do you make that work in a rigid format
of a component where you only have one
master element
and that's where the variants come into
play
and what you do is you click on your
component and to use variance you have
to have a component simple frame won't
work
and you click on this plus sign for
variance
now what a variant is basically it's a
variation of the same element so we are
still designing a button but depending
on the properties we have
we can actually make it look different
and for our case the property will be
color because it we are trying to
basically change the color from brown to
blue so the property of the variants is
color
now the first button i wanted to be
color blue so i'm going to give it the
value for the color property blue
and the second one
i'm going to give it
brown
and i'm gonna make it go brown here
let's go a bit
maybe
maybe red yeah i like the red better
actually let's do red
who cares about brown red okay so now we
actually have a button with two
different variations it can have the
color blue it can have the color red
and
let's just before we go on i'm gonna
show you an error type where what would
happen if we also name this the same
value blue
now then pigment gives you a problem
because
if you have the same values for the two
different variations figma doesn't know
which one to show it to to you when you
are actually fetching it
so you want to make sure that each
combination of properties and values
mapped to a single
variant maybe a single variation of that
element so this has to be red it can't
be the same
and what you do to actually get it is
you go to the assets panel again and you
fetch it just like you fetch a component
but now on the right side here you can
pick it and if you pick red
it's red
and let's copy and paste it here
and if you pick it blue
it's blue
look at that and that is the basics of
what we are going to use today we are
going to use throughout this whole
tutorial frames auto layers components
and variants
and if you are just new to this make
sure you go to the homework practice
file in the description just like i said
in the previous video
and
that might help you solidify your
knowledge but if you feel bold or you're
already comfortable with what i just
talked about
let's actually begin designing
and in this video i'm going to show you
how to create type system
basically we are using throughout this
let me actually go to a screen here
let me zoom in
let me go shift to zoom in yep so
throughout this app we are actually
using a single font called sf pro text
now
if you are using if you have a macbook
you can use sf pro if you're on windows
you can use sf pro text and again i will
add in the description how to download
this font if you are in windows if you
are a mac user it should already be
pre-installed when you bought your
computer or your laptop so while we are
using only one font
we are using it for different sizes and
one thing you want to do if you are
going to create a scalable application
is you want to create and determine your
type system early on so in order to do
that i'm gonna press on frame to create
a new frame
and i'm gonna name this type system
and i'm gonna move my profile again to
here
i always forget this guys
so
in here what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
have
i'm gonna press on t
for
this is a text basically i am gonna
this is gonna be my mainframe and i'm
gonna come back to check which kind of a
type can i use but then once we add all
the different versions of the type we
are going to use i am actually gonna
create a half i'm gonna show you how to
create a type system on figma so you
never have to visit this frame ever
again so let's begin what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna copy this
and i'm gonna copy this as again and i'm
gonna copy this again and you're gonna
have basically in this app two different
versions we are gonna have
12 pixel 15 pixel 17 pixel and 34 pixel
and we will have this for regular and
bold that's all the type versions that
we are using so
i'm gonna have this as my h1 meaning
title text
this is gonna be my title text
and this is gonna be my second header so
each
one text sorry h2 text
my bad so sub header i think subheader
would be a better
text and this is going to be 17 pixels
and 15 pixels is going to be my body
text
so this is going to be the
body text
and i'm going to also automate this as
well
and it then 12 pixel will be my smallest
text so span text
i'm gonna call the span text and in
mobile 12 pixels is usually the smallest
you want to go
for like icon labelization in ios you
can go 10 pixel but i wouldn't recommend
going below 12 pixel it's very hard to
read so this is the bolded version so
you can see each element here is bold
so now what i'm gonna do
is i am also gonna
select all of these and copy and paste
to the right side
here
and these all of these will be the
regular version so they will be the
regular version
oh yeah sorry my bad i was trying to
change the type this will be the regular
version here
boom
okay
so now that we actually have our types
every type we are going to use is here
we can actually add them to figma as a
type system so to do that i am going to
go over each type here
right corner style so i can add them as
a style and i can click click on this
and i'm gonna be here header
slash
regular
uh
my bad this one is the bold one right
yes
this this one is the bold one i have to
edit ah
ah matt you are making mistakes
ah
and that happens guys we all make
mistakes so this is the
bold one
and i'm gonna add this to be
header
regular
and i'm gonna add this one as a sub
header
bold
and i'm gonna add the
yep
another bold and as you guessed it
sub header
and this one will be body
bold and this one will be
body
regular now if you are asking why am i
adding a slash
and the reason for that is
i have to move my profile here i'm going
to move myself here
once you use a slash figma understands
that you are actually
basically nesting certain elements so
once i do header slash figma creates a
basically a title named header and puts
everything inside that i had like a bold
regular so this is much more easier to
read for our eyes
so the body is done next will be the
span so i'm gonna do the same here so
span as you guessed it slash
bold
and
i'm gonna do the same for this one
click on the plus span
regular
perfect
and i'm just gonna give it a check here
and now that we have this this is what
we can then i'm gonna show you how we
can use this a bit
so if we were to have a text here let's
say i am a text we can actually and
let's move this to somewhere else like
our
iphone screen here and these screens
will be deleted shortly but this is just
to prove the point of why this is useful
i can
change its styles here without ever
going to copy paste from here this is
almost like how we learned how to use
variants almost like a variance for
type but figma made it very easy for the
type system to do
to
actually have this very neat in the
sidebar here it's actually very neat and
now that we are done with the type
we are going to move to do this how to
create the style design system for the
color palette
all right so let's create our color
system
so to do this i'm going to go the same
thing i'm going to create a frame by
actually click tapping the keyboard
shortcut f
so i'm going to draw this out
and i'm going to name this
color system
and what i'm going to do is basically i
am going to
what this will have is basically every
variation of colors we will have in this
app from this blue and you can
see that we have different shades of
blue right so i'm just going to zoom in
here a bit but this is blue this is blue
we have white i believe
around
if you have a good eye you can tell this
is also some sort of a blue color
it looks black but it is also blue
and
we have let's say a gray color here
and the background of the screens for
this app that i designed aren't actually
completely white
they are like 98 white so that will be
added and those are the colors we are
gonna add so one thing we don't want to
do again is that we are trying to
minimize as much as how much copying and
pasting we will do for two reasons first
of all copying and pasting is very very
hard and time consuming especially if
your app scales and becomes instead of a
12 screen app which is here into 100
screen app the second is it is error
prone you might have copied and pasted
the wrong variation of an element you
might have copied and pasted wrong color
but if you have a system that you can
follow step by step you will also make
less mistakes and it will save you time
so let's go so i'm going to create what
i'm going to do here is i'm going to
press o to actually draw circles
and i'm going to make this like 120
pixels
120 pixels and these are going to hold
my colors
and i'm gonna copy and paste this around
i'm gonna copy and paste it around
yep four times
now i'm gonna pick all of these
i'm gonna copy and paste this complete
set of row
and that is pretty good okay
so now what we i'm going to do is i am
going to begin by the color blue
and the i'm going to go from 100 to 400
100 signals that it's actually a very
light color and for as the number goes
up it means that the color is getting
darker and darker so for this blue what
we will have is i'm gonna pick the
colorful tool and to do that the window
shortcut is i
and i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna go to the second color
and i think the second one here is
200 is this one this blue inside the
stepper
so i think that one so clicking on that
one is a bit difficult but i think i can
do this guys ready
i am so happy for that magnifier tool
and i think my just bugged out
yep that's your 200
and the 300 is the profile color here so
the icon color when it's not selected
that has to be zoomed out a bit more
i think i'm i think i'm just gonna
copy the color here the
tool is it's very small so i would make
a mistake so i'm just going to copy and
paste here
and the 400 is actually the text color
that i use i'm going to copy and paste
this as well
now
basically each row will serve as one
type of a color
so the blue is gone
what else can we have the blue is gone
we will have variations of white so two
variations of white
so i'm gonna move this and i think we
will have a gray somewhere so i think we
will have one gray
so for variations of white let's tank
this through first variation is the
input one so input color there is so i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna click on my
element and i want to
have the color fill i'm gonna press i
and i'm gonna go here press again
that's the
oh that is just white okay
and then i'm gonna press i and then i'm
gonna go copy the background and that's
the second one
so
and for the gray we only have the gray
here
for the disabled buttons
and that is your gray i don't think it
copied
let's see
yes now it copied and white is pretty
hard to see so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to give this frame a whole
dark background because we can't see the
white colors i i realize that so i'm
going to give it a black color here now
we can see all the colors
and now that we have this
what we can do is i'm gonna go through
the same process now at this point i
could use a plug-in to actually generate
these styles for me but i'm assuming
some of you have never done this kind of
work and it's beneficial for you to see
me on how to do this step by step so i'm
going to take the long route and i'm
actually going to do the same as what we
did in the when we were trying to
systematize the type settings so i'm
going to
click on this and i'm going to click on
this style
icon there and i'm going to click on the
add
and i'm going to write blue and as you
guessed it slash
and i'm going to say 100
and i'm going to do this for
almost all of them
and then 200
and
this is the part of
when you really
are happy that you have plugins
available to you that will automatically
do this for you but
it's good to
sometimes do it by yourself
so we again did the slash so we can
actually see them roll by row
and this is gonna be your
one so this is gonna be the white
hundreds
right
hundred
and this is gonna be the
y200
and 200
and let's see this is gonna be the
gray
100 okay
and let's see how it works right now i'm
gonna go on to the screen again i'm
gonna draw my rectangle on this iphone
and i'm gonna see if i can change its
styles and boom i'm gonna move my
profile here and yeah just like our type
system our color system works it's
easily scannable it's very easy to skim
and i'm pretty happy with it all right
so now that we have actually done the
color styles now we are going to move to
the icons we are going to create the
icon set that we will use for this
project in the next video
all right so let's actually begin
fetching our icon set now we are not
going to be creating all these icons
from scratch so what i did is actually i
created a frame called icon set and i
wrote down all the icons we need and you
can see the tenth one is bolded and
there's a reason why it's pulled just
wait for a bait give me a minute i will
explain now what i want to do now is i
am going to actually use a plugin to
fetch most of these icons and i'm
actually going to use two plugins the
first line i'm going to actually use the
plugin called feather icons
and the second one the last one the
store the visa icon i'm gonna use the
plugin called iconify now this is very
important and i'm gonna show you how to
actually install both of these plugins
so in the future you can also have a
starting icon set that you can use on
your own to save you time for your
designs and also it's a good practice to
learn how to create your work setup
where you actually can have the plugins
that you need to fasten your work so
let's install the plugins to install i
want you to go to click on the main menu
plugins and i want you to go to bottom
here and say bros plugins in community
once you see the screen i want you to
type feather icons this is the first
plugin we will download and i want you
to filter with the plugins here and i
want you to click on install for this
plugin once that is installed i want you
to write here iconify and i want you to
install this one as well now if both of
these are installed now you can actually
download these icons and i am not going
to go over the process of actually using
the plugin what i will do is basically
i'm gonna go to the feather icons the
first plugin we installed and i'm gonna
basically install all these nine icons
by fetching it here it's gonna be a bit
boring so i'm gonna actually speed
things up in the video level so that's
why all these texts are there and you
can also do this on your time and let's
go
and for the last icon i'm gonna for the
visa i'm gonna go plugins
and instead of going through
feather icons i'm gonna go for iconify
and i'm gonna look for visa
and i'm gonna pick this one
yeah i'm gonna put this here and you can
see all of these icons are actually i'm
gonna select all again
and i'm gonna
[Music]
basically create a
i'm gonna select all
it should show me
i think figma is backing up because it
should show me a spacing option as a
shortcut
yep there you are and i'm gonna have
this as maybe 24 that's better and
they're all spaced well right now and
one thing i'm making sure is the
bounding box that each icon has is 24 to
24. the inside icon size doesn't matter
as long as it doesn't go out of bonds
but for your styling knees it's very
important that each icon has the same
width and height of a surrounding box
now you will see in the design some of
the content meaning the actual
vectors might have different sizes than
the other icons but that's okay as long
as the bounding box is the same we will
make it work so now that the icon set is
actually created let's move on to the
actually
creating your first variations for our
first login and sign up screens
so before we actually move on to
the looking at the up and login screens
i forgot to do one thing in our icon set
so vial and i'm going to zoom with the
shift 2 here while you actually might
have get got the icons from the plugins
we use fedora icons and iconify one
thing i forgot was to actually make each
icon a component so we would actually be
eligible to use them from the asset spat
assets panel and the main benefit for
that is is you do not want to be coming
back to the screen to copy and paste
icons all the time that takes a lot of
time it's much easier to use the assets
panel and just drag and drop so let's do
that so i'm going to go to layers and
i'm going to go
on the left side i am just gonna
go through the i'm inside the icon set
frame i am
with shift i am mass selecting each icon
and then what i'm gonna do is i am going
to make these a component
and
let's see
ah
yeah thingama did not have that shortcut
did it so that just created the combo
mess so we have to go through the old
way i'm just gonna do the ctrl alt k for
each of these
and that is boring
i don't know if this has a shortcut or
not i thought it would
it didn't and it's crushed my dreams but
it happens so
let's do that
so now each icon is actually a component
and we can actually reach them from here
and that is very handy
so let's move now
into the sign up screen login screen
let's create our first variant so i want
you to take a look at this two screen
and i want you to basically
ask yourself two questions
what elements to visual look alike and
of these elements are they also
logically alike
what do i mean by this so when i am
actually looking at the screen what i
want to do is i want to systematize
patternize almost everything so i do not
do unnecessary work because in a
production level design like i said
previously you are not going to be
working with 12 screens we are going to
be working with 100 and if it's a web
app that is actually responsive it might
be 300. so you really want to minimize
your work and to do that we are looking
to actually create the variance well how
do we know which elements belong
together by answering those two
questions i said which elements do
visually look alike and for me right now
all these rectangles look alike
including the button but then i ask
myself which of these elements are
logically alike and i can justify saying
the input text field is
logically alike with the email text
input and the password is also because
they are all input text they are
basically all input fields but a button
is a button it has a different logical
functionality it is used to actually
have an action accomplished it doesn't
take an input so we are going to create
s
variants for the input field and it will
have three variants
the name
the email and the password and that's
how we decide things we answer those two
questions i'm gonna press on f to create
a frame
and i really want this to have a
different
background color because i'm going to
use a lot of
light colors i wanted to have a dark
color like the color palette and let's
press on f to create our frame and i
think the width of that is 325
what's the margin there 24 26 okay so
ahmed made a mistake to pass me
it should probably be
327 so it would have 24 pixels left and
right on a iphone device so 327 pixels
48 pixels for height and i'm gonna fill
this i'm gonna move my profile image
here i'm gonna fill this with the our
color style which are now here based on
our previous video i'm gonna pick the
100
i'm going to add this a border radius
because if you look this
input all of these inputs have a border
radius of 8
so i'm gonna add
eight here and i'm gonna give it a drop
shadow of
four or sixteen
and probably ten pixels and you probably
cannot tell how the drop shadow works
there because the background is what
would you say black but if it was white
this is how the drop shadow would work
and let's go to the previous i wanna
under the change boom so our frame is
good i'm gonna go back to there our
frame is good i'm going to rename this
as input and i'm going to rename the
parent as inputs
so it needs now a text
for the placeholder text i'm going to
write json mamoa i'm doing the text
input field and i'm gonna also because
we have the type system i'm gonna go and
say this can be a regular auto regular
body and that's pretty good and i'm
gonna make this out of it
and i want to basically align this like
12 pixels maybe yeah that looks pretty
good and so aligning text vertically is
always hard because even if you use
autofit there is always bottom and top
spacing so in this one you have a three
three and a half pixel on top of the j
and four pixel on the bottom so your
center when you are centering if those
two distances are farther apart you're
not actually centering the text because
the spacing is correct so this should be
maybe a bit
low
but it shouldn't be complete 15 it
should have
maybe 14 yeah that's how it goes
that's a bit better
and the color of it should probably not
be black but the gray
that's perfect
so now
now that we have our input frame we have
to make it a component so that we can
actually have eligibility for the
variance functionality so to make a
component the shortcut on windows is
ctrl alt k
and now i have a component and i'm going
to make this a variant by clicking on
this plus button boom and my second
variant will probably be the email one
so it would be jason at
hotmail
maybe x
jason
hotmail.com
you know if we have to make this
look production level
and now i have two
examples two variants of the input field
now what should my property name be and
to answer this to write this to answer
this very simply you should ask yourself
what is the attribute that i am actually
judging the difference of the variance
meaning what separates the variant here
what separates an input field from
another and in our case it's type if the
input type is password it will look a
certain way if input type is email it
will look a certain way so for this one
the type and it will be
text
for this one it will be email
and we should add a third one and this
is the most complex one
it should be the password one and i'm
gonna write this password
and it has actually an
icon at the end and it doesn't have a
it has the eye icon so you can actually
hide and show the password so i'm going
to delete the text it doesn't have a
text what it does have is the hidden
password right now so i'm going to press
o to create those hidden passwords
and maybe eight
awesome so those are my that's my circle
and i want the circle to be like
yeah
dark blue
and i'm clicking on alt to actually
drag to duplicate
and then
i am gonna do one more time
that's good
and i'm gonna take a look out to see if
this works and i think two works
and i'm gonna select all of these to
basically copy and paste
so
let's see
that i'm gonna select all of them to
basically
determine their spacing if i zoom in a
bit does things let me nope
but i think they are equal space so what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna group these
circles group selection
i'm gonna say
password text
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to add i'm going to make sure this
is aligned well
is it by 12
oh
what am i
clicking it's 12 so it matches the
alignment of the email field and now i
am going to add the
eye icon i'm going to my assets icon set
and i am going to drop the
okay
i think
we didn't i haven't got the eye icon
let's see
if i didn't
yeah oh i'm okay guys i think i skipped
it okay so i forgot to make the
component
so let me go back
so now i'm gonna select my frame
i'm gonna drop my eye right there
go to my layers my eye is there perfect
and i want it to be as away as possible
as 12 pixels
maybe one two
and what's it's yeah i think that looks
pretty good i think that looks pretty
good
one thing i want to make sure is this
one
two pixels i want it to be one pixel i
want the circle to be one pixel as well
and i want the whole eyes color to be
dark blue
we don't use black okay
and
that one works pretty good one looks
pretty good i think also so this one is
the visible i think we got the wrong eye
icon so
in this one what we have is that the
password is invisible so that's the
wrong eye icon so i have to go back now
and okay
these mistakes happen they will not
deter us so we have to install let me
quickly install the other
eye icon here
right there
yep let me put it
in the icon set
let me put it here
let me make it a component
and let me oh that's too much
let me zoom it zoom out
and i'm going back to my inputs
come on third time is the charm delete
that eye icon
click on the
password input go to assets get the eye
that is actually invisible
select its color to be dark blue
and we want it to have a stroke of one
pixel
and also we want to
let's see if we what's the distance yeah
we wanna give it
what is it now 15 12 and then we want
this to be 12 also and boom
yeah now it works all right so now that
so how this is gonna be used again is
now that we can go to assets and we can
have an inputs variant here like you can
see and if i were to drop one here i can
pick its version
if we pick password this test if you
pick email it's this so now that the
inputs is done
now we can i zoomed out too much now we
can focus on the sign
all right so now that we are done with
the inputs let's begin creating the
variants for the
large buttons which are the sign up
login buttons for our signing and login
screens but if you look at the other
parts of the app as well we can see we
are using the same button for booking
and we also have a different state of
the button which is the same width and
height but it's great so it's disabled
and one thing one more thing i want to
take your attention is the label in each
of these meaning label on each of these
large buttons is some of them is login
sign up book knob go to checkout the bit
of the
actual element doesn't change but the
size of the label is changing so that
means we actually have to use auto
layout to accomplish this functionality
so let's get cracking so to create a
frame again you know this now i'm gonna
press f
and
i'm gonna name this as buttons and the
reason i'm doing these all in different
frames is because as you can see
i actually the more type the more i
separate each component apart i will
have easier access in assets panel
because they will be much more organized
so in the buttons what i want to do is
it also i'm going to create click on f
again tap on f again and i'm going to
set this with the 327.48
i'm gonna change the
color of the buttons frame to match
the dark one here
and
i'm gonna add a fill of white there but
my white is actually specified with 100
same as what we went through for the
input fields it's gonna have eight pixel
of radius
and it will also have a drop shadow of
four four 16 pixels blur and 10 pixel
for the
actual drop shadows color
up for its opacity so now that we have
this as the starting point i am going up
and one thing i realized it is different
for the button is it's actually the blue
color so i'm going to change it to here
the initial blue
boom it also has a label just like the
input field but
the label is centered and that's
important
so it will be like login so the label is
centered
and it is also bolded so in here in the
input field the labels were left aligned
but also regular
but for the buttons it is centered with
bolded so they are also bold not regular
so i'm gonna pick my text of
basically bold 15 which is pretty good
and to actually accomplish the centering
i am actually going to use auto layout
and one thing i want to do is i don't
want it to hug content i want it to
fixed width
and height and there's a reason for this
so fixed center
fixed center
the reason is so i'm gonna show you two
ways of this okay so i'm gonna actually
drag another one so
so let's say how contact hunt content so
in this situation if i were to actually
add new text
you can see the the
content of the background also scales
but that is not what we have throughout
the application because despite the
changes of the label size horizontally
width and height of the background of
the button stays the same buttons width
and height stay the same and that means
it has a fixed return height but the
text is free to grow as slight as it can
so that's why we are using fixed instead
of hug so now that we are here
i i can show you now i can make this
grow
and the the
what would you say rectangle itself will
not resize and that is the key here so
now i have this what i will actually do
is that i am gonna make this a component
so that i can make then i have a variant
so i'm gonna click on ctrl alt k to make
it a component and i'm gonna name it
large button
and i am going to give it a variant
and what should the variant be based off
is again
the same question
and again what attribute are we trying
to differentiate we know the key
attribute we have right now is that if
the button is primary it's going to have
the blue background color and if it's a
secondary or
would you say if the button is active it
will have a blue color if it's not
active it will have a gray color meaning
it will be disabled you won't be able to
tap it but we can also have another
property here that is important such as
we can have and in this application for
large buttons like this we don't have it
but we can also have a secondary button
or a tertiary button meaning that
what would happen if we were to show a
button here like this look at the cancel
button here for the small buttons unlike
the primary button here where the button
is filled and it gets your attention a
secondary button is created with the
fill removed but only added in the
strokes so i think i will have that in
the large button just in case in the
future we might need it so i'm gonna
have two properties the first property
and again is
active is it active or not
and to add the second property i'm
clicking on the more options icon i
click on add new property
and then the
moment a bit of buggy here and the
second property will be
priority
and i'm gonna zoom in so what i'm going
to now do is i'm going to the first
button and i'm going to say active
yes
priority primary
the second button is also going to be
primary
but it won't be active
and when it's not active we want its
background color to be
grayed and we want the color of here to
be blue
and i don't want this to have a complete
white that's my mistake we have to use
our color system wherever we can
and so now we have two primary buttons
one is active one is not active and i
want a third one just in case that's too
much zooming in i want a third one just
in case here
gonna zoom out third one to be secondary
button but active
so what that means is it is active but
it is secondary and finger is giving me
an error because
it cannot have the same values as the
first one so now what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna click on shift x
to switch stroke and fill properties
and i am also going to give this
the color
blue there we go and that looks pretty
good so those are our three versions of
our colors and yeah so those are our
buttons that we can now play with right
just before we
go on board looking at sign up screen
began designing them i haven't mentioned
here so in the previous video we did the
button variations and one thing that
your test of adding new text here might
fail so here right now it is not
centering the text even though we set it
as fixed width and height because you
actually have to click here to actually
select where do you want the position of
the content p and if you select center
no matter what you add should actually
be recentered alone and that is how it
works and what i'm going to do now is
i'm going to do this for each of the
variants i'm going to check if it's done
here it's done if that here it's not
done so i'm going to do that here all
right so now all of them is done now we
can actually move to the login and sign
up screens
all right so let's go
so
and this is my tea
that tastes great okay so i i know
you've been waiting for this part so
let's begin so i wanted to show for our
frame we actually have iphone 13 mini
and when i'm going to do what i'm going
to do is i'm going to just press f and
i'm going to pick iphone 13 mini as well
and i'm going to pick it around here and
i want you to take a look at how to go
on and design this so when i'm looking
at this what i'm seeing is a basically a
background image with some kind of an
overlay on it we have the company logo
we have the
message if it's a signup it's welcome if
it's a login space if i'll come back and
we have some form to fill and at the end
of the form we have the option for the
user
if they have an account already they can
go to login if they don't they can come
back it's a very simplistic sign in
signup that doesn't have social media
account signing options etc so let's go
so one thing i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna need the sign ups
sign up screen
copy
and what i'm gonna do is i am gonna
right click and i'm gonna go for the my
plugin called on splash to actually find
the background image and if you haven't
already please install the plugin on
splash here and what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna look for travel and let's see what
we have let's see
i'm looking for this particular image
but i might not be able to find it but
oh i did i'm lucky so i actually got the
image um
you know sign up screen and
i think i did a mistake here where
i think the image is added to the whole
frame
that's not what i want i want the image
to be i want the image to be
on top of a
rectangle here i think that's what is
happening so i think i have to get this
overlay here yep i got this rectangle
and this rectangle is what i'm going to
fill the image as so plugins
unsplash the same process maybe travel
here
go down go down go down here
why is it
okay
now that is correct so
sign up screen copy
okay so this is correct now i'm going to
add an overlay to the image and i'm
probably going to add the overlay of
blue
meaning even in the overlay i'm going to
use our primary colors and
i am going to
go back here
get rid of that one
i'm gonna add an overlay
and i want the overlay to be basically
our blue color which is
basically i can do
i'm gonna press i for its color
and i'm gonna pick that
and probably
20 px 20
that's too little maybe 50 that's too
much
40
that's too blue so my blue guess was
wrong maybe maybe it needs to be a
darker color
so maybe
what we need to do is actually
we might need to go and pick our
dark blue color here
and copy that
remove that from our frame
go to our image go to its overlay and
paste it there
that's how is eight i'm trying to find
the maximum okay that's so i know eight
is too high
i know 20 is too low maybe 30 no
50. and what you can do is you can play
with as you are holding shift you can go
by 10
and probably around 55
or 45 is the answer i will go with 45
for now and that's how you find the
background
overlay color and you basically find the
up maximum and minimum bounce and just
play around till your eye actually
finds that okay this is the value that
makes sense
so now i am looking at i'm going to
design the logo
and i'm going to have a rectangle here
and i am going to make this maybe 128
pixels
and what i want is to have it for it to
have the initial blue color we have and
one thing that is different for this one
is that if you look at it
it's a rectangle but only two of its
corners are actually having a radius
so that's exactly what i'm gonna do for
this one and it's probably height is 40
pixels as well
yeah
maybe 60
but let's first add these edges
let's write 16.
do i edit to the right edge
i think so yeah
so maybe
64.
yeah that works and 148 and to see if my
height matches now and i could go the
easy way here i think for i think 48
would work
maybe 64. i'm not sure
let me check
i think this has to be bigger a
so for me to actually know i can just go
and copy the values but i want to train
my eye even though i designed the whole
app previously by myself this is not a
community project app what i will do is
it's still difficult to redesign
something what i will do is i will click
on shift r which lets me access the
ruler tool and i'm dragging a vertical
straight line here okay so for the width
i got it right so it is 188 pixels
and his height looks all right now but i
think the radius is
for this one a lot more so maybe
32
and 32
that is correct i think that works and
then i will add a text here
and it will be activista
and i want it to be autobit and
i think this is the only text because it
serves as a logo that we will not
systematize with our type and what i
want this to be is basically
36 pixels
maybe 20 pixels
and i want the second part of it to not
be bold
so i will have the second part selected
i'm going to make it a regular and that
works pretty good
and now i'm going to align this
let's see
and i'm gonna check how far away it is
and i think i want it to be 24
and
at 24 that is 42 so
at 24 i want the right part to be also
24 so it's centered so i'm gonna get
this to be
maybe around here
so maybe this can be 172.
and
and yeah i think that works
pretty
good maybe
17 and again
aligning vertically is difficult because
you can see top is six pixels but the
bottom is eight so
you you cannot trust the figma tool here
should probably be 16 to 15 and that
should work
okay
so
let's move on and we can circle back to
the logo again later so now what i'm
gonna do is i am gonna have my text
welcome
and this will basically be my header so
i'm gonna tweet it as a header
and i'm gonna automate it
and i'm gonna add the
exclamation point there and then what
i'm gonna do is
i am basically going to think about
all this big form assay frame
and inside this frame i will have three
groups
name group email group password group
and then button four groups maybe and
the input groups will have a
text label like your name and then the
input
and only the button will not have a text
label above it so it's going to be
like this so i'm going to go to my
assets
and i am going to go
and fetch an input
here all right
and before going further i want to add a
layout grid here so i can see things
better
and if you don't know what a layout grid
is it basically allows you to
4
16
it basically allows you to
use vertical and if you want vertical
horizontal layout of how your content
should be placed at all screens it works
very well so i'm gonna do that
so i can no okay that's at 24 pixels
go above and this is the name field so
what i need now is the
text label i'm gonna
uh undo
i'm gonna do [ __ ] zero
gonna go here text
i'm gonna say your name
and this probably should not be but
irregular but body bold
so your name probably two dots here
and i will have this auto bit as well
and i'm gonna check how far away it is
from the
text input it's 22 pixels that's a lot
so our left margin is 24 pixels so the
spacing i'm going to do
here is also important and how i'm going
to base it is basically i know our left
and right margins will be 24 pixels
so
i'm going to use the power of two for
each margin we will have between
different elements
and when an element is actually related
to a group of element meaning when you
are thinking of a
text input you cannot think of it
without the label of your name so they
actually should be closer to each other
than they are closer to welcome so what
i'm going to do is i am actually going
to reduce this distance to
12
and that should give me now 12. yep
that's pretty good
and i'm going to go to layers and i'm
going to
basically
frame these two things and i'm going to
write this as
text
input
[Applause]
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
copy
this one
and i'm gonna pick this one to be
email
and i'm gonna change this to your
email very simple
and i'm gonna
do it the same manner where i'm gonna
write this as email input
and then i'm gonna
drag this again and this will be as you
guessed
at probably
your password
and i'm gonna go here to my component
and pick its variant to be password
all right
so
now what i'm going to do is i am going
to add my button which is
our button is missing right now so i'm
going to go to our assets i'm going to
the button section i'm going to drag it
here
and i'm gonna go and make it go 24 and
it should probably be 327 what's
happening
and
that distance is too much maybe
around 30
and we can worry about the margins later
but right now what i want to do is i
want to group all these four things
and that would let me use our auto
layout function and how i'm i'm going to
show you in a second how we are going to
use it so i'm going to frame these
four elements as well
and i'm going to write them as the form
sign up form
and then i'm gonna add an auto layout
and what auto layout does is it's gonna
give me between each element so our
name frame email frame password frame
and our button
i want us to have
roughly
24 pixels
and that's great
and i'm gonna
basically i really want to
hide this
yeah i don't want to see the red colors
anymore i want to hide our layout so i'm
going to click on alt shift 4
to actually hide it
that's good
and now let's see how far away our
welcome text to our form that's 43
pixels so i'm gonna get it to be
maybe 24
and let's see how far i made that is 32
i think 32 pixel there works well so
from the logo to top that's 32 pixels
from here that's 24 pixels
and i'm gonna check with my ruler how
everything is aligned to the left
that is pretty good
yeah
i think this works so this is your sign
up screen guys and the only thing
missing right now is this text at the
bottom and this should be my bad
and this should also be sign up
and let's add our text
our basically gateway to the login
screen that says tab here if you already
have an account
and i want this text to be autofit
and i don't want it to be bold i want
it's
partially to be bold but
and i wanted to start at the same
left alignment which is 24 pixel for the
x coordinates
and i wanted to have because it's so
related to the sign up button i want it
to be like 12 pixels up
most so maybe 12 pixel that's pretty
good
and then i'm gonna make the tab here but
uh tap here
mode to be bolded
and i want it to be
again bolded
and it's color to be
blue
and that
works pretty good
i like what i'm seeing
i like what i'm seeing compared to there
now what i want to do is i'm going to
design the login screen and we are
missing the status bar
for these two screens so it doesn't
matter but later on the status bar will
kick in
and let's go and design the login screen
so what i'm going to do is i am going to
basically drag a copy of the sign up
screen and i'm going to rename it as
login screen copy
and
the first i'm going to look at the
differences the first difference is the
welcome back message which is makes
sense and then you can see the
alignments here of what is the same but
how where the text began is the same so
what we will do is
to keep the same alignment i'm going to
just remove your name field here
and then it goes up and i'm going to add
the
welcome
back
we probably want it to be uppercase i i
like it uppercase more now and i'm just
gonna drag this
but if i press shift you can also go 10
pixel up instead of normal one
and i'm gonna check the distance that's
12 perfect
and the text also has to change it
should be if you don't
don't
don't
already
i have an account
and that
works
yeah i'm looking at the login screen now
and that looks pretty good
i don't think it has any issues
i think i can ship this one yeah
let's move on to the next screen i think
the signup and login process is done
and let's move to the next things we
have to do and i think we have to do a
bit more variance before we can
all right so
let's think about the discover screen
and let's find out what we have to
design before
we move on to the screen what are the
elements we
have to add as variants so that we can
actually make it easy for ourselves when
we go to part two and we will copy and
paste
so that you know
we cut our workload again so
the
a couple of things that we don't have
right now is we do not have this top
status bar that i believe is present in
every other screen
and it looks like it has two modes in
the first mode it's in the dark blue
color
you know of our color palette and the
second part when it's behind an image is
actually white and then i look further
and i realize we have a new input type
and i think it's the search bar input
and that's a new input type and then we
have a new
element filter elements here one moment
filter elements here and it looks like
each filter element has two states
one is when they are unpicked and one is
when they are picked so in the london
case here we have a filter element that
is picked and then we have a filter
element that is unpicked
and then we have some cards and it looks
like we have a few different
options for them we have cities
one moment we have cities we have
activities
and it looks like each city has a three
different image and each active is a
three different image so i can see just
the cycling right biking biking biking
they are just changing its position okay
so then let's begin by actually
finishing the status bar so i'm gonna
create a variant for the status bar
first
so i am gonna do the same process gonna
press f
and i'm gonna name this frame
status bar
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
to pick its color i'm gonna
tap i
and then i copied the color from the
inputs
and now what i'm gonna do is i am gonna
copy this element and i'm gonna paste it
and the reason i copied this element is
the designing from myself is
i it was an element i actually fetched
from an ios kit so usually you have to
download the apple's resources to
actually get the top status bar their
design is very intricate it's much
better to fetch them yourself and then
change their colors for yourself then it
just designed from scratch
and i am gonna get this one's color to
be
blue uh
for this one maybe
we might need to go for
white background
and this will be a bit difficult because
we have a dark color here
and
maybe a bit of a lighter color because
we will also have a white variation then
because the background is white we won't
be able to see the white variation
so let's pick a background maybe
somewhere in the
bluish here
yeah that might work
and
so right now i'm gonna detach it
it was a component before i'm gonna make
it this bar
like
status bar element i'm gonna make the
copy for our sake so i'm gonna now make
it a component
and uh to do that i am gonna
press the shortcut ctrl alt k for
windows and then i'm gonna add a variant
to it
and i know now that we know that the
the only difference will be its color so
what i'm gonna do is i'm just gonna
basically say
uh the the properties value
the property will be color and we will
just pick its color so
for color this is dark blue
and for this one we will pick white
and
let's just do that let's just make this
white
and boom
and that works pretty good
so that's your status bar
all right so for the filter element i'm
gonna do the same thing i'm gonna create
my frame with the shortcut f
and let's put my frame here and i'm
gonna name this frame
filter
filters
and then what i'm going to do is
basically
i am going to create a
frame
let's say
maybe 32
and i'm gonna basically let it have a
stroke
and i'm gonna give this a 16 pixels for
border radius
and i want border radius or i want its
border color to be blue
and then what i want to do is i want to
add a text here for its label
and let's say
london
and i want this to be a basically a
regular text
so i want this to be regular body
so let's go to our regular body and
let's make this auto wet
and i want also this to be have a auto
layout
so that things always stay at center so
i wanted to have an auto layout
and i don't want it to hug its content i
want it to be
maybe i i do want us to
hug its content for the
wit for its height i'm okay with fixed
center
so
let's think and i want the color of the
text to be also the blue
and let's see how it works now
yep so when so it can it horizontally
moves it horizontally
increases its bit dynamically but for
the height we have a fixed height
so that's the
i think that looks pretty good to me
i'm gonna just check
i think this has to be at the center
yeah
i think maybe eight pixel
8 pixel
and
e24
yeah i think that looks pretty good i
think i like that much much more
so
now that i actually created a design
that i like
i want it to actually be a component so
i can actually make this
element a variant so to give it the
superpower of a variant i'm gonna go
through the same process of doing the
shortcut ctrl alt k to make it a
component first
and i'm going to rename this filter
and then i'm going to add a variant to
it
and
the
variant property we are going to use is
basically
uh
picked
meaning is the filter element picked or
not
because that's the only change that's
the only attribute that determines the
change if the filter element is not
picked
so this is a no
it will look like this if it is picked
so we have to swap the fill value so i
press shift x
and i'm gonna get the blue here and i'm
gonna make it white
and i think i might also make this bold
this time
yeah so that looks different and this
one has to be
yes
and yeah that is the filters
and now they should also show up so now
both of our
filters and inputs
and status bar show up in the assets
which is great for us to actually
actually use them on the left side
instead of going to their original place
now
let's move on to
let's move on to what else do we need
bottom navigation and let's get that
going
and in this design the button navigation
we don't have the other screens for the
user profile or settings but in the
future if we had wanted to grow the
application we will definitely need them
and for that reason it's probably a good
idea to have a
three variants for the bottom navigation
to have basically selected different
icons
all right so let's move on forward with
the button navigation and i'm going to
create the frame with the f shortcut
this should be very familiar together
guys now we have done this like 10 times
i'm going to name this button
navigation
and i'm going to take a look at the
button navigation
and okay so it takes the full
width of the screen and i think it's
between 48 to 60 pixels
and it has three icons inside so what
i'm going to do is
i'm going to go here and i'm going to
press f to create the base
and it's going to have 375 pixels for
width
as that is the vet
for the iphone 13 mini and i'm gonna
have it a fill color
and i'm gonna have it the color blue
and
now i think it's left top and right top
sides have a border radius
so i'm gonna definitely do that of maybe
12
so i'm gonna do
eight
oh 12 no 16
and here 16 nope that wasn't the right
one
uh 16
no
the middle one yes i always forget which
one is which
maybe not even 16 is enough 32 maybe
no i think 16 is the right one eh let's
look at back
yeah i think 16 is the right one
so
after this what i'm going to do is and
is the 48
right
i think it's a bit bigger than 48 i know
this this button is 48 and i'm gonna
catch with my eye
now i think it's i think it's
between 48 to 60 probably
let's say 54.
maybe 56
that's the 56.
when in doubt go multiples of four
and i don't remember what i designed it
to be but it should be somewhere around
56 54 52 maybe
but so then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to add the icons and to do that i
am going to go to our assets
and then what i'm going to do is i am
actually going to click on the icon set
and i'm going to have the compass
and i'm done going to have the user
profile
and then i'm going to have for the third
one settings
now
now that i actually got the content here
there is some stuff to do so
what i want to do is basically have the
left
margin of this bottom navigation and the
right margin of the bottom navigation to
be
24 pixels my mistake that's just a very
large zoom out basically if you guys
remember
how do we show this so
i'll shoot four so if you remember our
left and right margins is 24 pixels
mostly so let's get this to be here so
it should be 24 pixels for the left and
right and we can show this by
in our buttons here actually that's the
wrong margin but left is 24 right is 24
and we want to keep that for our bottom
navigation as well
but we also want these elements between
each icon to have equal spacing and to
do that we have to actually use auto
layout
so what i'm going to do
is i am going to pick these
three icons
actually i'm going to pick the frame and
i'm going to add an auto layout to it
and it's going to basically have the
horizontal that is correct if we go
vertical it's going to be look like this
we want horizontal
and we want each content to be centered
and then what we want
is basically
we want this to be
maybe
we'll just say the left margin to be 24
the right margin to be 24
and it is 46 pixels right now i think we
can increase the this to
maybe 16
and this to be 16 as well and that's
pretty good
and
maybe 15
14
14 might look better
yeah and 14 and then what we can do is
now the left and right margin my mistake
now the left and right margin is 24
pixels and distance is equal that looks
pretty good now what we have to do is
make this icon compass selected and that
would be the white
and i don't want the black color for
either of these icons so i would
actually make them go dark blue
and that's our bottom navigation now
that's just write
bottom nav
and actually to create the variations of
this we have to make this a component
again ctrl alt k
and then i'm going to add
two variations for this two more so
maybe one more here
okay and we should ask ourselves again
well what will the property be and
property will be the chosen icon so i
will write chosen
so
in the first one the chosen is pretty
simple it is the discover
in the second one chosen will be profile
and the third one it will be settings
now the reason i don't write chosen
screen is prop like
it would just be three dots and it may
be it's too large of a text for it to
show so chosen still makes sense and now
i'm going to adjust the second
button navigation element because
in this one what's chosen is the user
profile
and in this one it will be the settings
so
and
yeah i think that works i think the only
stuff that we have to change is i think
each of these are now
two pixels and i really don't
want our icons to have two pixels so
what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna go back
to the
icon set and i'm gonna make these
have
one pixel width
now that we are done with the bottom
navigation
we can actually
go and move on for the image cards
all right so let's move on creating the
variants for these
small
image card so
if you look at the discover screen here
we have
kind of two different
types of image cards the first one is
basically an image that actually showing
you the cities like berlin prague
amsterdam and in the other cars you
actually see the activities so the
discovery part one you are picking the
city with the cards and discover part
two you are picking the activity you are
gonna do in that city so that's already
two types of
variants we can we pick the variant
based on
its type of whether it's a city or
whether it's an activity
and
that is the way we are going to do but
what is also important is
if a variant is a city it looks like it
has three different types of cities it
can be prague it can be berlin and it
can be amsterdam and the image looks
different depending on what kind of a
city it is
the same goes for an activity the
activity can be eating the activity can
be hiking the activity also can be
biking so depending not only the type
of the cart which is
city or activity we also have specific
items that we have to account for what's
which city is it which activity is it
so
that's what we are gonna do
so
let's begin creating the variation now
you must be very familiar with this move
i'm gonna press f
for a frame shortcut and i'm gonna draw
this and i'm gonna say
image cards
and what i'm going to do now is once i
named my frame
i'm gonna i'm gonna tap the f keyboard
keystroke again
to draw my card
and i'm gonna give this like 156
108
and i'm gonna fill this first with like
white background but our white
and the background of this whole frame
i'm gonna darken it because it's very
hard to see
right now so i'm gonna
press i on windows boom
all right so
i'm going to add a border radius of 8
pixels and let's see if i missed
anything
i think
there is a bit wider i'm just going to
get the sizing from here
for this element that is 150 608 oh i
got it right huh my eye was correct i'm
glad
okay
so then what i'm gonna do is
i'm actually gonna
put in
the
i'm gonna go click it on my right click
and i'm gonna use the plugin called on
splash
so
if you haven't installed this plugin you
can just go to your
home screen and then you can go here in
your community again or you can also do
menu
plugins
and then you say browse plugins in
community and search for unsplash
now
this is a very useful plugin as it lets
you import images without leaving figma
it's a very good idea to have it
installed because as designers we have
to actually use these kinds of images
all the time and you really do not wanna
leave your work setting because it
actually disrupts your workflow
so
you can click on this
i
also it's installed already for me
so you will install this and then you
come back and you press right click to
use it plugins you find it and you click
on on splash
and then what we can do is we can look
for city
and then you can pick basically whatever
you want i think we had berlin
[Music]
so we can pick berlin here
and
that looks pretty good
what we can also do is we can just zoom
out and see what else is there so i am
realizing that a card is not just an
image but it is also an image with a
text on top of it now for us to have
that white text i believe we need to add
some sort of an overlay to certain
images
because if the image is too
let's say white saturated too light the
white font will not be visible
so let's see so i'm going to press t
for text
and i'm going to write berlin
and that is a bit difficult to see so
what i want is
i really want this
part of the thing and i want this to be
actually so the problem we are having
right now is if i add a draw if i
because the image is added to the frame
if i add an overlay to it will it work
actually that looks pretty okay
yeah no it does work
huh i thought it would also overlay the
font but it did not i can still see the
font clearly this might be a bug but hey
it works
so now that it works i am just gonna
undo the change and i'm gonna go to
where i am i want to be at 12
by 12 probably
so
12 by 12 that looks pretty good and i
want my font to be here
uh basically body font but bold
that first and i wanted to have auto
bits
and i want to check my surroundings
and
again it's the auto aligning for the
aligning for vertical space is a bit
harder so you can see the font actually
has a one pixel on its left so this
actually is 13 pixels in total so i'm
gonna move 11
and i'm going to look down and i'm gonna
have to move it up two pixels because it
has a four pixels
bottom oh my bad sorry
yes
so this and this is actually the 12
pixel look
okay now that i actually got my card
what i'm going to do is i'm gonna to
give it the superpower of variance i
have to make the component first i'm
going to press my shortcut ctrl alt k to
make it a component and i'm going to
rename this as
image
card maybe a large image card
image card
and i am gonna click on the variance
plus button there and boom
so ahmet
how many variants will we have for this
and that is a good question
so we already know we will have two
different types this is a city or an
activity and for each city or an
activity we will have three different
looks so three plus three is six
so that's how much we are gonna have and
then i'm also gonna go here
and i'm gonna go to this variant
i'm gonna remove its image it's overlay
and probably it's filled
and i am gonna go right click plugins on
splash
and i'm gonna fetch here prog
and if you haven't been to prague you
are missing out it's one of my favorite
cities
i'm just giving it
prague is a fantastic city
so we have berlin prague what was the
third city
uh my memory fails me come on
come on i'm at the amsterdam okay i've
never been to amsterdam i mean i've been
to the airport airport is nice i don't
know the city
but let's go here
let's delete this
and let's right click plugins unsplash
and let's pick amsterdam
let's see
probably this one
i think it's that one
i might be wrong but
yeah it's that one
okay our images look intact that's good
so the city picks are done now
i am now going to add the
activities and i'm gonna add
till six here
oops my bad
all right so i have now my six cards now
here okay
so the fourth one will be the first
activity and let's
delete the image delete the overlay and
let's make this
basically the activity of eating
because that's my favorite thing to do
i mean
what are what else are you gonna do you
are gonna walk the city and you are
gonna probably eat but there are some
people among us who probably like hiking
as well
well to each to its own so i'm gonna
just
remove the white as well i'm gonna do
plugins and we are gonna pick
where is the unsplash here i'm gonna
pick
hiking all right
and that's pretty good
and for the last one
we are gonna pick biking but to do that
we have to remove the image
and right click
this is getting pretty repetitive right
now
and i am going to ride biking
and i am looking for this dude right
here yes
all right so
let's
fix with our fonts first so this is
berlin this is prague
and this is amsterdam
and
so if you notice now
while we can read berlin pretty easily
it's very hard to read prague
and
one thing we really want to do is we
want all of these images to have the
same overlay because
if this design actually went to
production if a front-end developer were
to take this
project
they would probably tell you yeah i will
not go through each image and put
a different kind of an overlay this has
to be
general and so you don't want to give
them too much work
so what you want to do is you want to
find your worst case scenario meaning
the image that is lightest i believe for
cities is amsterdam
and for the active it's the berlin one
sorry it's the fourth activity it's the
biking one
and we are gonna
try to give these guys to overlay first
so that's what i'm gonna do 20
maybe
25
i think 25 will work
i think 25
will do the job
let's look at amsterdam our second worst
case scenario
all right yeah 25 works
so that's what i'm gonna do
five pixel 25
25 overlay
for eating as well
25
and that is pretty good
so now i'm gonna
actually rename these
berlin prague amsterdam this is
eating
this is hiking
and this is biking
all right so now that we are actually
done with the content of the variant
what we want to do is
we actually want to specify our
properties now our properties were
two-fold meaning the type
of the card is a city card or an
activity card and the second is its name
is it berlin prague amsterdam these are
all the names so what i'm gonna do is
i'm going to make my property the first
property to be type
and i'm going to go to the more option
here add a new property and i'm going to
specify this as name
and i'm going to go to my first one
and i'm going to specify type to be city
because it's a city and the city's name
is berlin
i'm going to go the second one
city
name
prague
and figma will give you sometimes errors
if you ever make a mistake
so it's now saying it doesn't have it
has an invalid name which is what we
want to avoid so we gotta give it
amsterdam
and you wanna now i'm on to the
activities so this one won't be city but
an activity
and it will be the activity of eating
oh i'm getting hungry
but
let's plug along this is hiking
and this one is going to be
activity
biking and i'm going to do a quick
overview activity hiking that's correct
always double check your work
city amsterdam city prague see the world
that actually looks pretty good and
though that is your
variance and just for the final check
you can go to your assets and now you
can actually see
let's open this a bit you can see the
image cards right here as an asset
that's fantastic
all right guys
so this part of the tutorial is done
oh now we are going to update our input
fields to add the search field as well
and let's begin by analyzing how it
looks like on the discover screen so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
click my screen i'm going to press shift
0 to zoom 100 percent
and off the bat what i'm realizing is
this if i'm comparing this with the
login
input field such as the email and
password
i realize that the height of the element
and the width of the total element is
the same as 48 pixels 48 pixels 327 327
pixels
now
search field also has a placeholder just
like the email and the name fields here
and the difference it has is it has a
button that is right aligned inside at
the search button and that's the one
difference that it has
and it also can have the actual value in
our design such as when a user actually
does an input or picks a filter element
the placeholder is replaced by the
actual text
label
what does this mean so right now in our
input variants we only have the
placeholder version for the my bad sorry
guys
we only have the placeholder version
right for the name or the email we do
not have an actual value version where
how the user would see this input field
if they had already put in a value so
that's also something we are going to
add and we are going to add this to
almost every element except password
because in terms of user experience
standpoint it is not a good idea to add
a placeholder to the past password field
because it is not that recognizable you
probably want to put it just
a line to your label
like probably around
around here if we were to put it to say
6 or 12 characters like give some
constraints on how the password should
actually
contain but it's not a good idea for
consistency to just do a bad user
experience so we are not going to have
the password field have a placeholder
but let's begin by adding our
search field and i am going to
make this basically
search
city or activity
and what i'm going to
then do is i'm going to press r for
shortcut i'm going to do this drag it
it's 40 pixels height probably and 64
pixels
width and i'm going to give it the
standard 8 pixel border radius that we
have and i'm gonna change its color to
our blue
and that already looks good i'm gonna
make it go align for shift
and maybe not that much but i'm gonna
zoom in
to see how am i doing four four
maybe
four four four
that looks pretty good
and then i'm gonna click on this element
and what i'm going to do is i'm gonna
right click go to plugins because i want
to add my search wait why am i doing
that i already have in my assets field
my icon set so i can just drop this bad
boy in
i can bring the search here
boom and that looks pretty good
i'm gonna give it the color of white
and i'm gonna
center these two okay that's pretty good
and i might even group these things
and i don't need them to be framed
like search button
and that's pretty good
and then i'm going to look
and
zoom out a bit that looks pretty good
so
what's this going to be is this is going
to be
search
but now as we said before only type
property will not be enough because we
also want to differentiate if an input
has a placeholder or an actual text so
i'm going to have to add another
property so i'm going to my variants and
i'm going to go to the more options and
i'm going to click i'm going to click on
the add new property
and i'm going to say
placeholder
and if it's a yes
and for this one it will also be a yes
and
let's actually show some versions of how
these things would look like so i'm
going to have
new
one for the text
and
one more for the email
so
and i'm gonna move this
up
and this is the hassle with the
variants i wish they had a drag drag and
drop right it would just resize
re-center itself vertically but it
doesn't
so i'm gonna drop these
yep and this one will be the
no
placeholder and this time it is actually
going to be
like jason mamoa
and it is actually going to have dark
yes
that's how it's going to look like this
is where a user has actually put in
their name
and right now we have the email and i'm
going to move this as well this is going
to be the email
input field with an actual value not a
placeholder
and aligning these things is a bit
difficult but we will do a polish soon
so
this is no
and
email yes place i don't know
and what we want here is this is email
and what we want this to be also is
basically
jason
hot mail.com
and i want this to be
dark blue
boom and that looks pretty good
then
what i want to do is i will not give the
second type for password in an actual
production we would actually have
password show and not show but in this
application we are not using that
variant so i'm not gonna add it
no need to go over perfectionistic here
but i'm gonna add the second version of
the search so in this search we have a
search and the placeholder is yes
and in the second one
which i'm gonna delete
because i'm gonna pick this and if i
press but like plus it will duplicate it
which is pretty good for figma
and it will be
london
and that will be dark blue
and that looks pretty good i kind of
like it
and that's now
basically align these things basically
space them
pretty good maybe distribute them
vertical spacing yep
and get them left aligned that looks
better
okay
so we are done with the adding the
search input field and we added the
other options for our
name and email field such as
adding the option type a placeholder or
not now i think we are ready
to actually design the discover screen
and
let's do that in the next video guys
oh now the long waited moment of
actually designing the new screen
and let's zoom in let's do shift
2 to zoom in and this is our screen
and we have a status bar which we
already created the variants for we have
a
text big title text asking where does
the user want to go and then we have a
search field we have the filters and
then we have the favorite cities as the
city is the first thing a user will pick
before an activity
oops my bad and so let's do that so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to press on
f and i'm going to pick iphone mini
and i'm going to drag the one that is
created to here
i know our design actually document is
getting crowded we have to actually
move things around a bit but i just want
to do this screen first before we do
that maybe finish the discovery part too
as well
so
now what we will do is basically we will
go to our assets and because we already
did the heavy lifting i'm just gonna
pick stuff i'm gonna go to my
i'm gonna
click on the status bar i'm gonna drag
one here
and i'm gonna
basically zero
for x 0 for y
and that looks actually pretty good then
what i want to do is i want to press t
for creating a text field shortcut and i
want to write jason
where do you want to go
and i know already that
the type for this will be bold header
so that looks pretty good and i do not
want this to be out of it because it
would what could happen is it would
actually
go over the
whole screen because it's too wide so
what i can do is i can give this
an auto height
and i want this to be left aligned
obviously and
let's zoom in here a bit and i want this
to have the color of dark blue
and that looks pretty good and around
here is pretty good
and where do you want to go
and that looks pretty good so far so
then what i want to do is i want to add
the search field so for that i wanna
okay so for this
and again the
what's happening is
all right the it's the media recording
software i'm using is bugging the figma
because it's basically overlaying it in
front of it and that is pissing me
off but hey we did it so
this one will actually be a
search
and look at that look and then we will
have
our filters and i am going insane with
my recording tools
guys
i never thought this would be a problem
but hey
if you are using a recording to irish
there was an option to pull it to the
maybe top side that would be fantastic
but
it's it happens it's not that perfect
for only so
i have my filter element now and what
i'm looking at this design screen is
we basically have a horizontal
scrolling view option means basically
the user understands they can actually
tap with their thumb and move to swipe
to right or left to move left or right
and that is only shown as a signal when
the
some half part of this filter
element is actually
hidden
so the user understands visually okay
for me to see the remaining part i need
to swipe
so that part is very important so what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna have four
i'm gonna double duplicate this
two three
and maybe four times but first let's
make this
istanbul
so istanbul
and what other cities do we have we have
vienna and new york
okay so let's make this vienna
and
let's
make the last one new york
and that one can be new york here
i'm double okay fingma is bugging a bit
new york
and that's good and then what i'm going
to do is i'm going to select all of
these
and i'm going to
frame them and then i'm going to
maybe make 24 pixel and i'm going to
move the x here
okay that's too much maybe 12
i think 12 is the right
i think 12 looks pretty good there
maybe
yeah 12 looks pretty good i'm gonna
check the distance between the top
elements
and
i want the search field to be at the 24
pixel
i want the text to be at the 24 pixel
and maybe
around here and that's pretty good
and then what i want to do is
i want to actually group
all these guys into a frame
and that is with ctrl alt g
and i will rename this as filters
and that's pretty good so now i'm gonna
go maybe one pixel up because it's 24
pixel it's consistency with the left and
right margin that is pretty neat
so i'm gonna go what else am i missing
i think we are missing the
i think the half of the screen is done
we might have some spacing issues we
might polish later on but let's just add
the new text now so i'm going to press t
for the text shortcut and i'm going to
write favorite cities
and what i'm going to do is i am going
to pick for this color dark blue and for
the text size i think i'm going to go
with the sub header bold
and i can make this out of it because
it's not that big enough to actually
go overflow of the screen
and
once we have our sydney text i can now
add the cards which we already created
the variants of so that's handy
so i'm gonna put myself here
for you guys to see and
oh
i'm gonna pick this one here
all right so we put our cards here and
now just like the filter element our
cards are also horizontally scrollable
and we do the same basically signaling
saying because half of the card is
actually
not seen on the screen the user
understands i have to swipe
and that's exactly what we are gonna do
as well
so
this is gonna be here
and i'm gonna do this
and i'm gonna do this
and
now
what we want to do is we want to grab
these three and make them a frame
so we can actually add some auto layout
so i'm gonna go layers
and i'm gonna name this as
favorite
cities i think
i think thing might put it outside of
our iphone frame i'm going to put it in
i think that bug
kinda tried to ping my sometimes bugs a
bit so what we want to do now is we want
to add an auto layout here
of maybe 24 pixels
that's that's too much maybe 16
maybe 12.
i think 12 does the job and we want to
center these
and we probably want them to be
centered here
and
now
what i want to check for is our
alignment for the
text so i'm gonna press shift r
and i'm gonna get it here
and we are almost there but i think
i think for the text we are good
i think for the
text inside the status bar we can do a
bit more left but it doesn't matter too
much because it's something outside of
our control we don't design these these
are given by the apple so i i don't have
a problem with that part
okay so now our alignment looks pretty
okay for the
vertical
now then what we can do is we can
actually
pick the cities so the first is
amsterdam berlin and prague
so this one is
amsterdam
berlin
and proc
and that's pretty good
so i'm gonna check its distance to the
top that should probably be closer than
24 pixels
maybe
16
would work pretty good here
and i'm gonna get even closer maybe
so what i'm trying to see is what's the
bottom
spacing here
it's i think four pixels
so if i get it to 12 it will actually be
16 pixel difference
so
that looks pretty good i'm gonna click
on it i zoomed out too much shift two
okay
so this looks pretty good i'm gonna add
the favorites to these text
and so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna so
cities this is favorite cities
cards
so if i were to put this text here
you wouldn't see the text because it
would actually try to auto layout the
text as well so that's not what you want
to do what you want to do
is actually we have to go back what you
want to do is you want to close this
cities frame and you want to frame these
two as well
and that will be favorite cities
that's pretty good so now we can
actually duplicate it by pressing alt
and drag
and we are gonna do that with shift so
it doesn't change
and that looks pretty good
so let's see
so one thing i want to make sure we have
is our bottom navigation
as well
and you can you see how easy it is to
add these things once you have created
the variants already
and oh i think our bottom navigation
width is wrong so
it might be a good idea to go back and
check it so it should be the whole
screen so that should be 375 pixels
so i'm gonna look at here
and i'm like okay
so mod would be 126.
okay that's too much
so for
here
what we want to do is
i think for the vet we want it to be
fixed
and that should be 375 pixel
and for each of these also the bits
should be fixed it should be 375 pixels
so let's do that
and these mistakes happens guys design
is an ongoing process nobody does it
perfectly one thing i learned from my
once i turned this into a full-time
career and i'm a full-time aux designer
we always make mistakes and you making a
mistake is actually your opportunity to
learn something and develop so do not
judge yourself as harshly when you make
mistakes we all do it's not an if but
when and
your reaction to your mistakes will
actually determine your outcome you can
choose to learn from them so i now
learned how to that i should double
check my bit when it's for variants
so i'm going to go back to the
to my nav
screen i'm going to rename it to be
discovery discover part one
and
for the
second part we have top picks for cities
so this should be top picks
and the third one should be
let's see under eyes
okay
so then
what we can do is
so i'm gonna check the distance between
these two that should be 24 pixels maybe
well it's also related so maybe 16
[Music]
as well
so then this one is also 16
and that looks okay maybe we can go so
in here i did 24 okay i understand
because they are each separate so maybe
10 so what i'm doing is if i press shift
it just does double so it just actually
does 10x so it moves 10 pixels down or
up
so i'm trying to get to 24.
so my math is failing me
and so in this one
the
in the second one the images
so
while we are using the same
cities we are changing their uh location
so this one will be berlin
this case and in this one this will be
berlin
and then what is the middle
so amsterdam is the middle
so amsterdam here is the middle part
and
this one will be prague
yeah
and that looks pretty good to me i'm
gonna do shift
i'm gonna just move
zoom out a bit
and that looks pretty good i'm gonna
check my spacing
so all of these can go one pixel up for
24 pixel
yep that's pretty good
that is pretty good and
yeah all these can go one pixel up
because it's a 25 pixel there
and
yeah maybe
maybe one more
so maybe everything in here
can go one more pixel up
and that looks
pretty good i'm just gonna check the
high so 68 therefore y
68 here yeah that is perfect so that is
our discovery part 1 screen
and
we can also do the second part very
easily what we will do is we will
duplicate this
screen
and we will rename this discover
part 2
and what we can do is we can actually
pick a city here and the top i picked
london but i want to pick istanbul my
hometown
so i am gonna actually go here i will
swa i will toggle it one thing figma
does very well on variances if you
actually created the variant property
and gave it the value yes or no it
actually understands that it shows it as
a toggle
so
yes no it's istanbul
and then what i want to do here is we
have a placeholder now
and
this should be not text but search
and
so one thing it doesn't have oh
so i think we made a mistake here i
think we
didn't create the search field
well so let me see here so what is this
field search yes
okay so in some part here
we actually made the type search and
placeholder yes have two different
uh
mappings meaning there's some another
element that also has the same values
here
so let's quickly search
search yes okay so this is
okay this is yes search this is search
placeholder now okay so now the mistake
should be resolved actually so if we go
here we say search
placeholder now
and we can type this to be
istanbul that is pretty good
and that is our second pick guys
it is our second discover screen that
looks pretty good to me
and yes i will see on the next video
so let's move on to the actual detail
screen i'm going to zoom into it by
pressing shift 2
and this is after we picked a city and
we picked activity this is the screen we
see and i'm looking at the screen and we
already have the status bar we already
have the icon for this we have the
background image which where we know we
can use unsplash to actually get it and
we have the text here but one thing we
do not have is we do not have these
avatars and this is meaning these
profile pictures with the labels below
them that tells the
user who who are attending and what are
their names who will you meet
and we also don't have the
the small link here so
if you look at this link like this
c-more and c-all is a bit different
c-more is basic it's going to extend but
sealed is probably going to create a
pop-up co is almost like a button here
and it's something we call a tetriary
button where it's not even a secondary
button with the
stroke around and with the background
like in our
large button
let me show you so it's not even this
but it's almost like it doesn't have a
background it's just a text with the
underline on it but it still functions
as a button then we have these cards
which we don't have so it looks like we
have three four things here we need to
do the avatars variants so that we can
actually have multiple versions of this
you probably need a small button
variations right now we only have large
button variations but we know in the
next screens especially here we will
need smaller versions of those buttons
and that's an entirely new category
itself so they will have to be a new
variant group and then we will need
these cards these
benefit cards i believe like this
activity is cost friendly or this
activity can make you friends or
something else
so let's begin with
the
avatar
variation so what i'm going to do is i
am going to zoom out a bit and i'm gonna
play press f for short key
for frame and i am going to title this
frame as
avatar
images
and then i'm going to do shift 2 to zoom
in and i'm going to press all for a
shortcut for a circle shape
and i'm going to make this basically 48
by 48
and i just want to check if it is 48
let me check it looks like 60.
is it 60 i want to see
it is 60. okay
not wrong because 48 look just a bit
small to my eyes so let's do 60.
and one thing i want to do is i want
this
circle to first
not actually have a fill
and i want to right click and use my
plugin
user profile which will actually give us
random profiles
now
ah to actually install the user profile
plugin i want you to click on top menu
go to plugins we did this before now
actually installing a plugin and
and then what you can write here is
user profile
and once you're done i want you to
filter by plugin not files
and then i want you to install the first
one here
and then come back
so once you install you can actually use
the plugin now so right click go to
plugins and go to your user profile and
you have a few options now i want male
female i don't care
and i want to insert a random photo
and then what i want is i want to press
and i want to write here what does this
guy look like he looks like an anton
i do not know why but he does
so i'm gonna make this a
[Music]
body regular
and then i'm going to center these guys
and i'm going to press both of them
and i am actually going to
frame these two together so i can create
them a component and then make them a
variant
so this is my frame of
uh maybe large avatar
because i know in the later screens we
will have a small avatar so large avatar
and then now the next thing i want to do
is i want to actually make this a
component so i'm going to press
ctrl alt k
for shortcut and now it's a component
and i'm going to add
a new variant what is the attribute we
are doing basically depending on the
name of the person their looks is going
to change now of course two people can
have the same name and their face will
not be the same but not for our avatars
if the name is different they are
probably going to have a different image
okay
so
real life exceptions don't count so i'm
going to right click by selecting the
circle i'm going to go to user profile
and i'm going to insert another random
photo awesome and that looks like to me
mary
i'm literally judging stock photos here
but that happens that's life
so i'm gonna click right i'm gonna go
plugins again
user profile
the same
okay
george
and
one thing you can do here is
actually is you can do an auto layout
for vertical
and then you can center and this is a
very good idea for each of them because
like we see here if the name gets too
long we stopped being centered and you
have to then spend time centering things
and that is not an ideal use of our time
so i'm gonna do auto layout
and i'm gonna center each of these
maybe two pixels
yeah 2 pixels might do the trick
actually
and add the auto layout
center
and 2 pixels
there we go okay so george is good
let's add a new one and i'm just gonna
add a new one so five is good enough
so let me replace these as well
okay
all right
i'm gonna name this guy
luke
and i'm gonna
name him matthew
alright
so this looks pretty good
so we have the avatars now and now one
thing we don't have is well we have the
content we haven't specified the
property or the values so right now if
we were to actually
create
like fetch an instance here
we would not we would just have variant
two variant three those are not name
those are not
values that we could actually
remember six months later when we are
going to use this
variant and say what is variant for
but the name is much more memorable so
that's what we are gonna do
now the property is going to be name
obviously
so
name and then i'm gonna go through each
and i'm gonna give them the name anton
mary
and this process might actually be
boring but it really pays off guys
because
this is the only repetition we will do
anything else we will do is when we are
going to use this on design is just drag
and drop
all right i think i'm pretty good with
my avatar images
and i think they look pretty good
all right so let's move on to create the
next
set of variance and i want to do the
small button versions basically i want
this this is our one of the tertiary
version of our button
and on here we have the secondary and
the primary
so i'm going to zoom out here
and i believe we do not have for the
small buttons a disabled version
i think we might actually add it
a disabled version might actually work
well
so
what i'm going to do i'm going to
actually buttons here
and
i am going to add this variant to the
buttons but what i'm going to do is i am
actually going to
inside here i'm going to
click on the frame and i'm going to
press f
to create
create the surrounding box
for my small button
and this is probably gonna be
32 pixels
maybe 96 starting i mean it will have a
auto layout but let's say 32 pixels
and 8 pixels border radius
okay so
what we will now do is we can fill it
with let's say white but
probably blue
all right so let's get this and let's
put the text on it
let's say done
oops sorry guys my typing skills are not
that good today
and done and
bodybuild that is pretty good i want
this to be out of it
and i'm gonna have it here and i'm gonna
click on my
frame here and i'm gonna rename it as
i'm gonna rename it as small button
perfect and then i'm going to add an
auto layout on it
and i probably
want to make its vet
for now fixed
and centered
like
maybe it can grow
but i just want this to be like
yeah that looks pretty good to me
actually
it's in version that looks pretty good i
just want to make sure i want to double
check if i got the height right
and it looks like i did get the height
right maybe
it can be a bit wider
right this is a bit wider
so
maybe we can do that
make this a bit wider and the other
label we can use cancel that is actually
a bit longer so what we can do here is
we can center it
and maybe do 32
32
and
maybe not make it fixed
and that might be pretty working and
let's see if we add text it will
actually dynamically resize it well
so that's good because we want the
cancel to actually have the same padding
as well but let's make the
height of it fixed
and let's make that center
okay because i will make this a compound
by pressing ctrl alt
k
and now it's a component i can make this
a variant
boom so this is our primary button and
how we are going to do this is basically
we are going to have just like our large
button we are going to have an active
state or a priority state
and
because in the future if we don't know
if our small buttons can also be
disabled so for now we can just add them
and in the future they might actually
come useful so let's add the property
active
and then i'm going to click on this more
options button to add a new property and
the second
property will be priority
all right
so
okay so i'm going to go to the first one
now and this is active
that is
yes
and priority
primary
and i want this to be our
secondary button so
i'm gonna click on the button and i'm
gonna press shift x to actually switch
the
fill value with the stroke value and i'm
gonna click on that
label and i'm gonna pick
blue
and i think we have to make this our
white here
yes
so this works pretty good
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to press
to create another variant but before
that i am going to say
yes for active
but priority is secondary
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to create third theory and for
that what i will do is i will actually
i will get
probably i might get rid of the
surrounding uh
i might get rid of the surrounding
button here
so what i will do is i'm just gonna come
here i don't want a stroke value there
and i want to resize it to the i want to
resize the surrounding frame to the
width and height of the text so i'm
gonna hold alt
and i'm just gonna
yep
maybe a bit larger
so just a bit larger so that
it doesn't cut off the labels
and that is our third here button
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna click
here
and okay
and let's go up here and say active
yes
and priority
tertiary
which is a very hard word
and let's check if this one also goes
out of bounds okay so one problem we
have here is this
if we actually increase the
width of the element
it doesn't increase with the element
itself meaning the auto layout doesn't
resize so let's check
if we have the auto layout
so
let's look at here
yep probably want to hug its content
it's just maybe we can reduce the
padding it has
yeah so this might work better actually
yes this works better
so how about we do it this way and one
thing we want to do one more thing is we
want to underline this
so i'm going to
go to its label
and i'm gonna
go where is it
so that is correct where do we underline
this
i am searching on figma
all right this style alignment now
maybe control you
now
okay so let's go
here
text
underline
hmm
i think for some reason this did not
work
why would that be
okay
for some reason the underline doesn't
work i do not know why it doesn't work
so far
but we can figure this out later i will
figure this out on my own this is the
this is the small buttons we have so i'm
going to rename these as small button
that's correct and this one is large
button and we should be able to see it
in the assets
and
let's close the editor images button
navigations
and if we scroll down and move
on the bottoms we have now the large
button and the small button and that's
perfect
i will see you in the next video
all right so we are going to design the
benefits cards in the details screen but
i want to tell you that i found a
problem with underline here so
if i'm clicking the text and i look at
the more options i can see that it is
actually selected as underlined so the
problem is we do not have enough margins
at the bottom to show the underline
and to actually do that we have to go
back to the
frame of the label
and
if you look at here our vertical spacing
is fixed so first we have to actually
make it a hug content and the moment we
did
our
height stretched a bit to the
surrounding
margins that we had specified
and now what we can do is we can reduce
these to the minimum amount that will
still be enough to show
the
what would you say to show the
elements underline an element itself and
that looks pretty good and then what we
can do is
we can actually make the
now we can actually make the height
fixed
and that is yep that works
that works that's the one
so we have our underline there now so we
can move on so now i will move to the
details screen here and our so
our secondary button our small button is
done as a variant our avatar is done now
if you
can see here these are our cards our
button overflows them actually because
our booking now button actually has a
primary importance
but
actually in the background you can see
these cards listen like what is special
what is the benefit of this
let's say activity
why are all these people going and
so for that what we have visually is a
basically a
white rectangle white background we have
a text at the center of it that is
vertical and then we have a icon on the
right side in a circle
that is enclosed with a circle so that
is what we are going to design
so i'm going to go
and press f
we are going to make this a
variant as well
as you know because we might have
different variations and i'm going to
name this
benefit
card
and i actually am also going to
get its color to be with eye to this one
because it has it is going to be a white
rectangle it's hard to see on a white
background as well
so i'm gonna press f
and i know the vitalfit with the circle
is 327. so if you pay attention here
you zoom out a bit
let me go back
so you can see that the button which is
a 327 pixel width has the same width as
the
card but for the card you have the
rectangle and the circle at the right
top side so it is the
rectangle
plus the circle size that ends up having
the
same bit as the large button we have so
we gotta calculate the size of the
circle as well it's probably 24 pixels
but it's at the middle part so the
calculation is a bit tricky
so
that's why what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna fill it with white immediately
and i'm gonna give it a stroke here the
same stroke we use 4 to 16
10 pixels
and i'm gonna make this also have eight
whoa
all right and we probably want this to
be
like 48 as well
that is too much
what's happening so maybe 256.
yeah that kind of looks okay but
maybe
we can get this to be a bit longer and
i am literally just exploring sizes here
maybe this can be 32
32
and i know its color is actually the
blue that we use
so if i were to add this here
if i were to look at both of these
frames
okay how do they look like right now so
this is going to be
the card
background
and this one will have a text inside of
it
that will say
let's just copy and paste the text there
so let's just ctrl c
come back here
yep
okay
wait where is that circle okay that
circle is there i think the text
disappeared i'm gonna recreate it and
i'm gonna paste this okay
then i can actually make this out of it
that's good and i'm gonna make
this text to actually have the style of
a normal body it is regular
perfect
and
let's look at it so it's 15 15 i want it
to be 12 and centered
and
again centering is usually difficult
with vertically as we talked about
let's look at the spacing here
three and a half four in the bottom so
we are much more biased uh for the
bottom
so we want a bit more on the top
so
that looks pretty okay yes
so that looks a bit more centered and
now what i want is i want this button to
actually have an icon as well so i'm
going to go here
nope i already have my icons in the
assets panel
and i am going to pick the money
and
that
kind of looks a bit too big what i will
do now is i will actually head over to
our
icon set and i'm going to resize some of
the icons because as we talked about so
here where we made the icons components
so as we talked about while the
surrounding box of the icons are the
same the sizing can actually change and
we might want to have different sizes so
this one is actually like
let's see so let's see the inside
elements for the
dollar sign
i'm gonna go layers
and that's 12 14 that's 22. so i want
this actually to be resized and i wanted
to have
i want to use my icon resizer frame
how you can install this you can go to
plugins and then you go again browse
plugins in the community
and then you can type here icon resizer
and then you will go on plugins filter
and then you can install it
and once you install it come back to
here
click on plugins and go to icon resizer
and this lets you specify an icon box
site which is 24 pixels which we want
and maybe the maximum height to be 16
and that's pretty good and i'm going to
do that for most of my icons here
so i'm going to do icon resizer
probably 16
[Music]
and i'm gonna probably do it for this
one as well
plugins icon resizer 16
okay
and that looks pretty okay so far
i won't do it for my bottom navigation
or these
i think those two or three will be
enough
yeah i think those two or three is
enough so let's go back
and actually add our
actually delete
actually now that you can see it
actually shrunk a bit which is good we
are going to pick its color right
and that
kind of works
so
now i am going to actually group the
ellipse with the dollar sign
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to rename this as the
benefit icon
and now what i'm going to do is
i am going to frame i'm gonna
get the card background frame and the
group and i'm gonna
frame these as well so i'm gonna press
ctrl alt g for frame
and this is gonna be my benefit
card and then i'm actually going to make
this
a component
and i'm going to add a variant
perfect and my second variant is going
to be
let's look
and before adding the second variant i
think we forgot to check the size okay
so our size is still pretty small
so what we can do is so i know this
circle
actually will be half the
it's
with inclusion it to add its width we
are only adding the half of its bit to
the total because it is at the inside of
the card a bit
and that is like 16 pixels
327 pixels is the total width v1 so this
should actually become 311.
so
and then this circle should move
so let's make this move 10 pixels
okay
and let's
let's also increase this
sure
okay so
this is getting a bit buggy
okay
so
right now it's not centered yet
correctly
i
think okay so this is 32
i think that is pretty correct so far
okay so let me see the total with here
326. so maybe we are missing in
okay
i think this can be now correct
okay 327 64 pixels i think that is right
i want to see if the height of this
element was 48 pixels it might be
32 in the actual design
let's see let's go back and let's zoom
in
and let's see
inside that was 50 actually okay so
that's actually pretty long element i
will keep it at 50 i will keep it at
48. and that is our element so now we
can just add the second
variant
and i'm gonna get it to be a bit closer
and this one is actually going to have
an attribute of
benefit
and this one is
going to be
budget
friendly
and this one is basically going to be
maybe exercise
and i'm going to get the text for the
second one as well
from our screens
so
yep so i'm gonna just
ah just
yes
okay let's say this active helps you
burn calories figma is breaking out a
bit
so i'm just gonna say this activity
helps you burn calories
30
and that is a very weird saying activity
helps you burn calories
and that looks pretty good i'm gonna
replace this icon inside as well
so i'm gonna
add
the
icon of the exercise here
and i'm gonna
change its color to white
and that is
perfect
so
that is
pretty good
i think that does look pretty good
but
let's see i don't think that's putting
the same
so i'm going to just get this to be here
and yeah that is our benefit cards guys
let's see if we forgot anything
i don't think we have that looks pretty
good
only thing we have to do is make this
exercise that's good
i think we can now
actually begin
designing
the detail screen
[Music]
all right now that we have actually
designed the variants we need for the
details screen we can actually begin and
design the details copy screen so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to press f
for shortcut
frame and i'm going to
click on iphone 13 mini
and i'm gonna rename this as details
copy
and what i'm gonna do is so basically
first i need
a status bar so i'm going to my assets
and i'm going to close my icon set
inputs
and just going to grab a status bar here
and i'm going to put it to zero
0
and so one of the things i'm realizing
is we need a
basically a rectangle element for the
background image so i'm going to make
this 375 pixels
maybe it's like 192.
might be a bit bigger than that one but
i'm gonna make this go zero zero
and i will go to layers and i'm gonna
rename this background
and then what i'm going to do is i am
actually going to go plugins
and i'm going to add an
image here from the unsplash
and it is the same image we had for
biking
and yeah so that's the image i'm going
to add and maybe
256 instead of yes
that looks better and
i know that this needs an overlay so i'm
going to add an overlay
percent actually looks good maybe 25
and that looks bigger and now i'm gonna
zoom in with shift two
and i'm gonna compare here so what i
need right now is
so i'm going to move the status element
above the image so it will actually show
and i want the status bar to be
basically white
and that looks pretty good
and then what i need is the back chevron
icon
so that the user can actually go back so
i'm gonna go to my assets
to my icon set and i'm gonna get the
chevron left icon here
i'm gonna put it around there and i'm
gonna basically select its color to be
white
and that's pretty good so far then i
will add my text for biking
and then i will add my load um some text
so i'm gonna copy this
and i'm gonna t and i'm gonna just copy
and
paste here and this is probably gonna be
just a
regular
and then what i'm going to do is i need
for the location my location icon
and for the pricing i need my dollars
icon so
for that i am gonna
bring my dollars icon here
and for the location i'm gonna pick my
map icon
and that looks pretty good
so i'm gonna look up
and i'm literally just adding the stuff
we need like the bottom navigation
so i will just move my profile here
so i'm like bottom navigation
and you can go in any order you want for
these i just know let's see if this is
complete bottom
yes i think this is
it
for it yep i think that is vertically
and horizontally centered let's just
zoom in a bit
to see if we are
actually centered at well
maybe we went overboard a
yes that is the
correct coordinates
and then
we have a
basically
a long paragraph with
about but let's finish the basic card
design with the activity background
there
so i'm gonna get another t for
london
ontario location
and i'm gonna make this
autobit and i'm gonna make sure this is
regular and then i'm gonna make sure it
is actually
white here
and i'm gonna make sure that the
location icon is also white
perfect
and then i am gonna make sure biking is
actually a regular header 34 bold
and i'm gonna make it out of it as well
and we are getting there i believe we
are getting there pretty good now in the
original design there are some mistakes
that i'm not repeating here like
this sharing icon to match the other
icons actually should be
is 2 pixel but in the new design we
decided that we want each stroke to be
one pixel so that's okay
and i'm looking i think i'm also missing
this
38 dollar person
yes
and so
let's begin arranging some stuff
and i'm gonna
basically put this at 24 and what i want
to do is
i actually want to see the layout so i'm
going to do
alt shift 4
oh that didn't happen so
ctrl shift 4
sorry yes ctrl shift 4 to see the
layout columns we have and
in this one so what i want is i want a
layout grid
i want to do columns
5 margin
24
that's also 24 maybe 16.
yeah
that works so based on this i now know
how to actually align my items
and so it should be around here
and this one because
like we said a horizontal alignment is
also sometimes difficult because
you see the
fonts which is starting from here the
actual font is for the biking b starts
here so there's like three pixels
of empty space
and when you are aligning things those
three pixels matter so that is how the
proper alignment would work
and
this is around there so what i'm going
to do now is i'm going to get
london ontario and
location icon
and basically move all of them
just a bit yes so that mattress
maybe get the london ontario a bit
closer and i'm gonna make these centered
that's pretty good
and now what i'm looking for is what's
the distance i think it should be around
12 to 16 pixels there so i'm gonna group
these
i'm gonna actually frame these so this
is the location
location info
and
this one
so for this one
where did our
i think we had a dollar icon but it
disappeared oh it's there
i just didn't change its color so let's
get it to white
and let's
frame this with ctrl g
and
let's just go to layers and let's say
price info
for them i'm like okay
and let's move this
here
and let's
make our stream smaller
and what i want to do is i actually want
to do an auto layout to our frames
and this i'm going to center them
and that's pretty good and i'm going to
basically
press
ctrl
or
i think
no i think it looks pretty good right
yeah i think what's the distance between
these two that's one pixel
i think it can be
so if you zoom in the surrounding so the
icon inside the locations is like four
five six pixels away so maybe two pixels
would make it eight so i'm gonna make
this
two
and i'm gonna add an auto layout here
too
i'm gonna center it and i'm gonna make
this two as well
and then i'm going to get these to be
aligned
and i'm gonna zoom in again
and these have to be moving to left a
bit
so that we have a left alignment with
the biking
this one needs to be moving here yes
and then
i am gonna get this a bit closer
not that close
but somewhere around
here
yeah somewhere around here would work
what's the distance here
so that's eight pixels
ten
and i wanna look at here two four six
seven that's 18 pixels so maybe
one two back and that should be around
16 and that looks pretty good
so
now what i'm going to check is the
distance between here
that is
let me zoom out a bit
that is
four pixels eight pixels plus 11 here
and that's 1922 23 that is too far away
so
what i'm gonna do now is that
i am actually gonna go up and compare
and contrast
so you can see how our bottom here is 24
left is 25 that's something we want to
do as well
so i'm gonna
decrease
the height here a bit and i'm going to
check its contrast that's too much so
this should actually be
from 24 in the left to 24 at the bottom
so
and now that we align the height of it
to the actually baseline in the second
line
this is actually pretty accurate 28
pixels is a pretty accurate tire so i'm
gonna
maybe
24 perfect
and i'm gonna get both of these to be
down as well
maybe here
15
and 19
so maybe one two three
that's pretty good and i'm gonna get
this down as well
and that is
three
eight and
up three eight two that's fifteen to
sixteen
maybe one more up and at sixteen and
that's pretty good
so what i will do now is i'm gonna
actually
look out and decide if the position
if the positioning of the arrow icon is
pretty good and
i think it is
like we can always get this time to the
left like we have it above here but that
is actually in the production not in our
control
like these are things that you get
custom
from the apple ios kit
so you actually don't have much control
there all right so onward to the second
part i'm gonna press shift two to zoom
in
and what i'm gonna do is i am gonna
press t
for text shortcuts and i'm gonna write
about
and i'm gonna
actually go and copy all this paragraph
till here
actually all of them actually yes
here
copy all of them and i'm going to
basically press t again
draw one and then paste all that text
all that websome text and i'm gonna make
this
basically go
regular 15
left aligned
it
and
now one thing that actually we might
need to do here is
we might need the
15 pixels here it's
let's just finish the let's do the
header first because i think our spacing
is a bit different so you can see here
we are a bit spacious and we are at 17
pixels so maybe not the
body regular but maybe regular here
that looks a bit better yeah
so i think this height is a bit better
and what i'm going to do is i am going
to pick this as bold sub header
and i'm going to make this go out of it
and i'm gonna
make sure that our color here is dark
blue
and then i'm gonna go up
and i'm gonna do the attendees as well
so i'm gonna drag this
header with the alt press and i'm gonna
basically write here a 10
these 34.
i'm going to make a left
line here
and i'm gonna also make this go out of
it
and maybe
here
it's a pretty good idea then what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna add our avatars
you didn't think we would use them did
you so i'm gonna go here move my
profile and i'm gonna go avatar and i'm
gonna add them here
so this is anton and let's see how many
we have there we are roughly five four
six and because we can see a beginning
of my next hours are just at the edge of
the screen so that signals to the user
that you can actually swipe that's
exactly what we are gonna do we are
gonna then have six avatars
so let's do two three
four five six
and let's
select all of them and make them a frame
ctrl alt g
and then we will write this as avatar
frame
and we want the auto layout so we can
add spacing around tanks maybe 16 pixels
and we definitely want to center things
and we yes we definitely want to center
things and now we we probably want them
to be around
here
something let's actually
how do we center this thing so let's
let's see i think this is the center
for us that's not quite right so let's
think this through
maybe 12 pixels
because i remember how it looked and
okay so
is it true that we got six of them yes
so maybe 24
okay so our spacing is too small so
maybe 24.
let's see
so
yeah i think 24 is the spacing we used
24 is a bit too much and it's
you know i'm not respecting the
horizontal distance here so because in
here it was 12 i think 12 will work
better so i would much rather ask to
have 12
around here
so i'm just gonna
do okay so that's 25 to 20. so maybe
let's check now that's true okay i went
the wrong way to three
that's 21
2
okay so let's see maybe
minus 22.5
and that's perfect and now let's pick
everything to be different so let's pick
this to be mary
let's pick this to be george
let's pick this to be look or matthew
and lo
no let's
pick that matthew and let's anton again
and that's fine
so and the distance between the avatar
and the attendees should be roughly 24
pixels
but we will get there
so
next i think what we need before we
space things up is actually get
everything we need so we need a
small
territory button here so i'm gonna
select the details go to assets again
and we will go to buttons now and we
will get a small button
and we will make sure that it is active
but
territory
and that will be like see all
all and
let's see
okay so here's a mistake so
so we
needed to be hugging its contents but
then why is it not hugging the content
of c all
so what did we do here
maybe we gave it a second okay it's
because we made it not have auto of it
but no it should have auto of it so okay
so that looks pretty good see all here
is that right
okay so maybe
like the initial s is capitalized
which is fine
all right and maybe this one's too okay
so that's a bit better
let's enter this
a bit
up
all right
and let's
check it here we need the cards for the
benefits
and so i'm gonna open here
and i'm gonna definitely get my benefit
card
right here
all right so my benefit card is there
and i'm gonna get rid of the
the
columns there ctrl shift four okay that
looks a bit better
and
so one thing that
i want to check is what is the
color of this
details copy and it should match our
white here
that's good
okay
so this should be 24.
yep
and
so i'm gonna get this up as well
i'm gonna check so this should so there
is a bottom margin here of four pixels
so this should be like
twenty
one two three four
okay that looks pretty good
and
then what i'm going to do is i am
actually gonna get this
up as well so i'm gonna check 24 and
it's
this for this paragraph i don't need to
go and check because it's line height
matches where the frame
where its
actual height is so 24 pixels per tag 24
pixel there is actually 24 pixels so
then what i'm going to do is
i am gonna
press ctrl shift 4 just to see where i
should have ended here and i'm going to
zoom in a bit
so this should be a bit to the right
yes
i think that is correct
and maybe down
yes
that works
i'm to move my profile here
and then i'm going to check the distance
between there
that is also 4 pixels so that should be
also 20
because 4 plus 20 equals 24
which is the distance we are looking for
that's good
and then
i'm gonna
make this to be 24
but i'm gonna get this height to be
nope my bad
set
i'm gonna check
maybe
24 here
and then i'm gonna
copy and paste it here
like that so it's like so i can drag it
here
and i'm gonna go layers the problem
right now we have is that
the benefit card is above the bottom
navigation which is not what we want so
i'm gonna pick the bottom nav here
oh my bad guys i'm gonna pick the bottom
nav here and actually move it up so it
is actually above the benefit cards
it's around here
and i want this to be exercise
and i want the distance between these
two
[Music]
yep
i want the distance between these two to
be
i think
i think around here let me just move
things here
yeah
so i think we can give it this height i
think we need a bit more height here so
i'm gonna make things smaller
so now i can actually move these two up
and i'm gonna check
that's 24
i think for this we need 20
that's 20
and for these we will get them up two
that's
24
and for this i want 16
as they are the same elements and that's
pretty good
then what i can do is i am gonna get my
so i'm gonna check
how far away am i and i think i'm
missing a bit so okay so with avatar in
the previous app i actually had just 16
pixels
and with this i just had
okay so i just had 16 pixels there so
maybe because attendees is related to
the avatar that makes sense
to maybe move them up a bit so one two
three four five six seven eight
and that should give me 16 pixels there
and but these for these i am gonna move
up
yep and
that is pretty good
okay so now i'm gonna add my main button
logan i'm gonna add here
and this should be 24 pixel to the
navigation so it should be one two three
four five six
and that should be
the
book now
okay that's good and again the main
difference we are having here is i'm
going to press shift 2
and press shift 2
so i am looking here and i'm gonna
change its color to be
one moment i made a mistake i'm gonna
change the text color to be here
dark
blue that is fine it is blue that is
blue
and yeah i think those are pretty good
i think i'm gonna get rid of the columns
now
and let me check
that looks pretty good
compared to our original sample
i think our coloring still hasn't
updated
but
let's do maybe
white 100 yeah that looks pretty good
yeah
i think for some reason we are not
getting this color
i don't know why
like this is the white color isn't
updating well i will figure that out
later
but for now this works i like it i think
it's a bit more spacious
than what we have here but i still like
it
and one thing that it has here is this
yeah overall it looks pretty good
i would say so i think it all looks
pretty good
yeah
i'm proud that looks pretty good
all right so that is the details copy
guys
i'm gonna check here
that looks pretty good
i think these two need to be
centered yep that looks better
i think that's the only part
but yeah i think this looks pretty good
i'm very proud
and in the next one we will go on to the
variant so we can actually begin the
scheduling screens and i will see on the
next video guys
right so the first variant we are
actually going to design is this drop
down
so to show you what this is i'm going to
press shift 2
and basically we want this to have two
options one is when the drop down is
closed and then the other is when drop
down is open and it shows date picker so
basically we will have one state where
the property is open
or
meaning is the
drop down open and it's a yes or no
value so let's do that
that's basically
go
here press f
and
do and right drop down
and then i'm gonna press f
and before that maybe change the color
of background to be this
and i'm gonna then
go to the draw go
zoom in shift to
and then i'm going to close the benefit
card and i'm going to find the drop
downs
and i'm going to add a fill to the
white and i'm going to make this 8 and
i'm going to make sure we have white 100
and i'm gonna get its height to be 40
pixels as that is the standard
height we have for the
most elements and then i'm gonna make
its
overshadow to be 16 pixels on blur
and 10 percent here perfect
and i'm gonna probably get its split to
be 327.
just in case it takes the whole bit of
the
available content area on the iphone 13
mini
and then i know it has a text label so
it should be like
pick a day
and
let's think this true and i'm going to
zoom out a bit
because i'm realizing maybe there is
more than two values
so i think there is two more than two
values because or maybe there's two but
when it's closed you have to select a
day but when it's open
you actually
you
actually have to have here an actual
date
okay so
there is a mistake here in this design
where
so can you see even if the person picked
the 30th it should actually write 30
june 2022 but the design here is wrong
so
so the drop down can have multiple
values in the first
i think that there are okay there's two
different properties the first one is
this is the drop down open or closed
but the second one is does the drop down
already have a date or not if it doesn't
you should write select the dates but
the dropdown also might have a date that
was picked but we wanted to change so we
will have open we will have s properties
open
and we will also have date packed or not
yeah so that would give us roughly four
versions so i'm gonna go here
i'm gonna zoom in here and i'm gonna add
the in the assets the chevron
we have
from the icon set let's begin with the
share run down
and let's pick its color to be dark
[Music]
blue let's pick this color to be dark
blue as well
and then let's check the distance here
that is 12
and 15 15 and let's give this the
15 auto
and that's pretty good and we want this
to be 12 as well
so this will require a bit zooming in
here to find out
all right so
in here we have 11 and there is five
pixels so
we really want to go
maybe seven
yeah i think that's right so and then we
want to go 12 here
i think that should give us this
that should give us 12 by 12 left and
right
that's pretty good
so pick a day i don't need the auto
layout here because the date will never
be that long
so i think i will just make this a frame
now with the ctrl alt
g
and i'm going to write this drop down
and then i'm going to make this a
component with ctrl alt k
and then what i'm going to do is
i
actually will
give this a variant
here
and
i will give the property the first
property to be
open
oops
open and i will go to the more menu add
new property and that is
has date
or let's say picked date
okay
so let's do this so
so let's say select the day here is
better
select
okay so for this one what we have is is
it open no
is a date picked no
and the second one what we can do is
we can actually pick a date where we can
say 20 22
june 20 22
and what this means is we are are we
open no
have we picked the date yes
and then what we can do is we need two
more of these
and so we will have four variations
and in this one we are also are we open
yes and when we are open we do not
and let's say let's pick the date no
when we are open the share run down icon
actually has to turn into the share run
up icon
so we need to get rid of the share run
down
we go to our assets
and we get a share run up icon
and yes that is the way
and i'm gonna remove this so that's the
share run down and i'm gonna just
basically give this to be the same x
coordinate
296.
and i'm going to check if it's equal it
is equal
and
then what i'm going to do is i'm gonna
press and now i want this to be picked
yes and i'm gonna give this
20 20 to june
2022 and that's all of our options guys
good morning everybody so let's actually
move on
with the
looking at the scheduling sessions i'm
gonna show you here
so before we actually get to design
these screens there's one more variant
we need to actually
finish and that is the date picker you
can see this element i'm gonna zoom in
by pressing shift two and you can see
the state picker and basically what
happens if any user decides to pick a
day for their activity they click on the
apple drop down and this opens up and
they get to pick the month the date etc
now the
hard part with this element is actually
the content of the days
because you actually have two ways to
visually create this content you might
actually do it column by column like
this horizontally or you might do a draw
by row by row and to keep each spacing
equal you have to use auto layout
otherwise you have like 60 margins that
you have to align yourself between each
date like between 1 2 and 1 8 and 8 9
and 8 15 and this just cascades
and for me i found it much easier to do
auto layout with the row by row solution
so that's what we are going to do now
before we design again we have to think
what are the states of the speaker in
terms of variance and there is two
states as far as i can see the first is
basically a date picker that doesn't
have a picked date yet which is this
side
and the second one is a date picker that
has a picked date which is this one
where we have the blue color
so that's what we are actually going to
do
and i'm looking at what we need and one
of the things we need right now is this
right chevron but if you look at here we
don't have a right share run on our icon
set so we actually have to go back that
was a mistake by me so we actually will
go scroll here
go to our icon set
and let's look at here so let's see
this one here
and i think what we need is we actually
got the same one
so what we need is a right share run so
i'm going to right click
go to plugins
and we will go to fedora accounts which
was the plugin we used to actually fetch
our icon set and we are going to write
chevron
and i want the right chair run here and
i got it
that's pretty good i'm going to my
layers now
and the hard part really is that
with figma sometimes it's difficult to
actually put
things like plug-in icons into the
what would you say
into the frames because they don't you
they don't put it usually often so like
it put it outside of our icon set frame
even though we put we actually fetched
it inside so sometimes you have to do
this manually like this
go and put it there and once we got it
we have a few things to change again our
color is never black we want dark blue
and then what we also want is that we
want the stroke width to be one pixel
so i'm gonna go inside and i'm gonna
pick fun
and now that that's done we will
actually make this a component by ctrl
alt k
so now again ctrl alt k
so now our chevron write is a component
and it should show up in our assets you
know
panel
and let's look and it's there all right
so we are ready and done with our icons
so now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
actually create the frame that will hold
the variant so for it i'm going to press
f for frame shortcut
and i'm going to write here date picker
and that's all good and swell so then
what i want to do is
i want you to take a very good look at
this visual
because what we have here is basically
seven
lines i seem like monday tuesday
wednesday thursday fridays
saturday and sunday and we have at most
six rows so we have seven columns six
rows
and how we are going to do the design is
basically row by row by row so it will
be like
row here row here row here
okay i think i made a mistake i think i
should have done it fit the column i
think i'm mixing what i call them in a
row is and i apologize for that guys but
let's look at my solution okay so i
think i did it by
column by column right yes this is a
column this is a column this is a column
okay column by column is a solution and
i named them wrong these are all columns
so that's what i will do column by
column by
i apologize guys
it's been a long tutorial
all right so let's go
all right so i'm gonna go here
and i'm gonna first change the
background color to this match this one
and then i'm gonna get
i'm gonna zoom in with shift two and i'm
gonna press f to create my frame parent
frame and this is gonna be 200
327 pixels we know this because it
stretches to the left and right sides of
the margin of the screen
and for the height we are going to give
it right now 256 pixels
now i don't know if that is good enough
we might increase it if we need to but
let's go so i'm going to fill it with
our white color and i'm going to
actually add a border radius of 8 pixels
it already started looking nice i'm
adding a drop shadow
4
16 10 percent which is our general drop
shadow and now what we can do here is
this
we can press t to add the text let's say
june 2022
and i'm gonna make this a
basically a regular
sub header
and i can have it here
and i'm gonna make this autobit
that's pretty good and then what i can
do is i can actually fetch my icons that
will let the user pick the amount they
want to pick on the right side here they
might select on the right side so i'm
going to get my share on left
and i'm gonna get my chevron right
okay
so chevron right was a bit harder but we
got it
and i'm gonna actually maybe get these
guys a bit more
closer now maybe a bit above
all right
so
then what i want to do is i want to
do my first column so that would be with
t
and what i'm gonna do here is
basically
i'm gonna do
m
and
i'm gonna make each of these
take the autobit and it won't be a
subheader it will actually be a regular
body text and i'm going to zoom in now
so what we need here is
so this is m for monday and what we need
here is first 8 15 22 and 29th of the
month
so then i'm going to like have to drag
this basically and this is going to be
one
and this
is gonna be eight
and ahmet are these dates accurate for
june 2022 i don't know
i didn't check the calendar
maybe they are maybe they aren't but i
don't think it matters much
this is a prototype after all but it is
29
and that's the first column
so what we want is that we actually
want to make this a group here
so we want to do this we want to frame
this
and we want to make this the first
column
all right so first column works
and then we wanna basically
duplicate this
but first let's give it a bits of
spacing so between each element we might
want 12
and we probably want them to be right
aligned
yeah i think i like to write a line
better maybe center might also work
and we will figure out what kind of an
alignment we want but we can check our
solution again if i did center or light
so let's check it
okay i think we did center in the
solution which is fine
sometimes you can also do write a line
if it suits you it really is your call
but one thing i want to do is i want to
make the first m which is the date
to actually be body bold
and i also want each of the text color
to be dark blue not black
yes
i want this to be dark blue as well
okay
so that looks actually not bad so i'm
going to actually drag this to duplicate
and i'm going to drag this okay i'm
holding shift so that my horizontal
alignment doesn't change four
five
six
and don't worry about the horizontal
spacing between each column we will
actually accomplish that when we frame
each of these columns into a parent
frame and that will let us put
horizontal spacing
distribution the way we wanted
so this is actually so i'm gonna go
tuesday
and this is 2
9
16
23
30
and this one will be 3
10
17
24 and 31st so any element after this
actually we made a mistake
will not have the last
row
because 31st is the most you can go
so what we will do is we will remove
this
and we will actually drag this one
and this one
and this one yes so that's monday
tuesday wednesday
thursday
friday
saturday and
sunday
yeah i think that looks pretty good
so
excuse me let me just drink this tea
it's very early in the morning so i need
my energy okay so 2 9 3 10 17 24 31st
this should be 4
11.
if i make any mistakes guys please don't
tell me
i'm kidding you can't tell me
we all make mistakes it's okay
especially this early in the morning
this is 12 this is 19
and this is 26.
i definitely made the typo summer
6
13
20
and 27
and then here is 7 14
7 14 21
28
okay that looks pretty good
all right so now
what i want to do is i wanna
select all these columns that we did and
i want to frame these by with the
shortcut ctrl alt g
and this is the dates frame
and i will what i will do is i'm going
to check the spacing between each
element here which is 12 pixel and they
are centered
and what i will now do is that i am
going to
add an auto layout to this parent frame
and i'm going to make this 12 as well
now
ahmet is 12 enough
probably not because if you think about
a person is going to use this app on
their mobile phone and you probably want
a much more margin between each number
because you want this to be very easy to
tap between thumbs so let's try 16
for the columns as well so let's try 16
here
so i'm gonna just go through all columns
here
and
yes i'm gonna go through all columns
here
so 16. so what i'm going to do is i
might speed up this portion of the video
i'm just going to go through each column
and make these 16
and
i will see when the
actual design of the dates are done
yeah i think that looks pretty good
so now another thing we need is our
cancel button but also
before that we should realize that 256
wasn't enough
so i'm gonna actually add 32 pixels
there to 888
that might be better and even this might
not be enough but let's see so another
thing that our actual element needs is
the
small secondary buttons so i'm gonna
show shift to
so look at here we need the cancel and
the done button and then we will also
add these circles that the
basically if a circle is not filled it
signals what day it is right now unlike
the time you are using the app and the
blue circle that is filled means that
that's the data you actually pick the
activity to do
so
here is a good question that the
previous design here didn't answer if
you are on 29th june 2022
should you be eligible to pick the dates
beforehand you already cannot go back in
time
so that is actually a design mistake
you already cannot go back in time how
can you be on 29 june and have the
option to select previous days
whoa that's a past mistake for me
all right yes let's let's correct that
shall we
let's let's do better
yes that's the motto let's do better
so
first we are what i'm going to do is i
am actually going to add our buttons
first i'm going to get our small buttons
and i'm gonna make this active yes this
is gonna be a secondary button
and this is gonna be
cancel
yep
and cancel looks pretty good
and then i'm gonna duplicate this by
dragging
and this is gonna be a primary button
saying
done
okay
so far so good
288 is definitely not enough maybe three
or four
okay so now what i'm gonna do is
i am going to pick a date here
and i am basically going to let's say we
are on the date 16th okay
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna press
all
and i'm gonna put it oops my bad i'm
going to press o and i'm going to put it
around here
and this is going to be 24 to 24
maybe 32
32
and it's gonna have
no insights and it's gonna have a blue
around now i'm not gonna put it inside
our date frame because the moment i do
it will try to arrange it to like a date
and our alignments here will get messed
up so one simple trick you can do on
ping maze i'm just gonna use the
coordinates to pick a date so i'm gonna
go to left
so i'm going to literally i'm holding
shift so i can move 10 pixels at a time
and i'm gonna go up here
and i'm not gonna align it like this
maybe here
and that looks pretty good
and i think this one is also supposed to
be like
blue here
that's the date you are on and any date
before 16 means that it's not eligible
for you so i am actually gonna
almost make each of these dates to be
like the gray
yes
so i'm gonna make these gray
which is a disabled color that we have
so that is 3 4 10
and i'm sharing these mistakes with you
guys instead of redesigning everything
because
i think it is good to see other
designers i actually am a full-time
designer and i make mistakes all the
time man i make mistakes all the time
and i think it is a very good thing for
beginner or even mid levels to see that
other people are making mistakes while
still having a career and that's fine
that's how we learn i think it's a very
important thing
so
now the first day from the first to 15
is actually disabled we are on 16th
and that's the first version of the
let's say design that we have now we can
actually worry about the small things
like spacing
so
what i'm checking now is i'm checking
the distance between everything i want
this to be probably 16
or maybe even 12 nothing is 60 i'm gonna
check our card design to see
how what was the difference there like
what was the margin left and right
because we want to repeat that for
consistency
so i'm checking here and it was 12 by
12.
okay
so let's do 12.
i'm going to go here shift 2
zoom in a bit more
and let's go here 12 by 12.
so i'm gonna do
12 here
12 there
and i want to make sure
that
that is roughly 12 but that should
probably be eight
for the text
what's happening
oh like eight
yes
and
both of these guys can actually go
here
and i'm gonna check the distance here
and that should probably be a bit closer
because of the surrounding box
and
i'm gonna check here
okay so that's roughly 9 12 that is
correct
and with these icons you usually eyeball
it if you are very very
detailed you can just zoom in and count
all of the rectangles which is what i
usually do
but
let's
get this to be and let's see if it looks
like
it is so let's select both of these
elements
okay so it's almost like it is hitting
the baseline there which is the where
the most weight of this font like it's
not the baseline but
where is the most
weight
of this font of this type street that
which is in the
like around here right it's like it is
not here because most of the focus of
this font because we are using a
lowercase for most of the letters is
here
and that makes it look pretty centered
because that's where the
middle part of this meets
and i'm going to check the distance
maybe get it here
maybe i think this separation is pretty
good so that
the
elements actually maybe they can be a
bit closer
yeah
i think that's a bit better yeah i think
that is better
and
another thing that we can do now is
we can also check our spacing here
so we probably want to go to 12 as well
that is not good so that is yeah that's
pretty okay
now
we might not be able to do 12 because
now the problem is that while we are
consistent with our card design spacing
the hard part is that
our outer spacing is much more than the
inner spacing we have between each state
right the the
the marginal difference between 16 and
17 is 16 pixels while the whole parent
frame at most has 12 pixel difference
which is why it makes it look like we
are very squished so you want to really
have
parent margins to be bigger so probably
we will go with 24 and break the
consistency
so that should be like 20 here
and 24 here
and that should be like
here
and we should take it also here
yes that looks a bit better and let's
make this go 24
maybe for alignment 22 yes
and let's get you guys to here
and let's look at your bottom and let's
move you guys up a bit as well
and that is
so the distance between these two
elements is 12 pixels 8 plus 4 that is
12.
that is a pretty good distance
so
what we can do is we can actually check
again
12 so
like
it's almost
good and you can see this element
actually
isn't doing the like it's not fully
scratched i think it looks pretty good
right now in terms of spacing
i'm eyeballing it a bit but it looks
pretty good the problem here is that the
circle our circle around the 16 is not
centered now and it is bugging me so it
should be maybe around here
nope around here
yes
no around here yes
i think this now looks better and what
i'm going to do is basically i'm going
to write this as
i think we did it is the date picker
right yes
picker
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make this a component now
oops sorry i'm going to make this a
component with the ctrl alt k i don't
want to frame a frame i want to make the
frame a component and that let's
substitute the variance so
remember from the beginning of the video
we know that they will only have two
state states the first one is that the
date hasn't picked it is not in pick has
not been packed the second state is that
the date is picked so for that
we need the property of
date picked
so
date picked
and for this one it's a no
and for this one it should be a yes and
we should change stuff
so
what we should do is let's say the user
also let's click let's drag this
okay that won't work
so
let's make a copy of it and let's just
basically drag it here
let's just say they did 18
and i'm gonna press shift x to swap the
value
that didn't work why is that
okay so for some reason figma doesn't
let me swap values i can do it the old
way
i can do it like this
and the hard part here is that my circle
has to be below my dates which is what
i'm gonna do so that the date is visible
and i'm gonna press for this one i'm
gonna make this white
and i think i'm gonna make this bold as
well
yes that looks a bit better
and i think that looks like a selected
circle
yes that looks like a selected date i
think that looks pretty good
i think i like what i'm seeing
what is the
horizontal margin between these two
maybe it should be 12.
i really don't want it to be not
multiples of 4 12
and that looks pretty good actually
so that is our date picker
all right so let's get started with our
first two screens for the scheduling
ones so what i'm gonna do is
like always i'm gonna create my initial
frame
so i'm gonna press f
and i'm gonna pick iphone 13 mini
and i'm gonna fetch it here
and i can do this as schedule
part one
now here are the elements that we
already designed
for our variants to actually for the
screen is we have the status bar done we
have our button is done i think we might
not have the disabled version i will
check but our large button is mostly
done we have the bottom navigation and
we have the date drop down now what we
are missing is the stepper functionality
for the adults and children here now
i do not think these will actually need
to be variants or the stepper function
needs to be actually variant because
now we are not using it as any other
parts of the application you might
actually make this in the future for a
variant but for this tutorial's sake and
to
maybe not
prolong it any further i'm not going to
actually make the data variant i'm just
going to design it here but as a
homework if you want to bonus points
from me and show me later and email your
work to me you can make the variant on
your own so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna just add our stuff
that we have to use so like the i'm
gonna move my profile here and i'm going
to add the status bar let's say
here
i am going to where is my button i'm
going to add the drop down here
where is my bottom navigation
show me where is it oh it's here
okay
so i'm gonna add this okay so the bottom
navigations coordinates is
760.
and that looks pretty good and this one
should be
zero
zero
yep and that looks pretty good and then
what i can do is
i can actually
get the from my icon set i'm gonna get
the left share run which actually lets
us go back one step
so
what i'm gonna do is i am gonna go find
our icon set and i'm gonna drag the
chevron left right here
and i'm gonna go to my layers
and that worked subliminally pretty well
and i'm gonna get this to be like 16
or let's see let's see from here what
was the coordinates so 16 yes i was
right
so then we can get it here this would be
24
and so far so good i am now gonna check
our
i'm gonna check our large buttons to see
if we have a disabled version
if not meaning disabled variant if not
we will need to design some stuff and we
do
okay i'm proud of us so we actually have
that one
so now i can also then that means i can
also shift to i can drop our large
button as well
and i can disable this it's not active
no
so
let's look again and this is the go to
checkout part
to
check out
all right and it's centered perfect
so the only thing that remains now is to
design the things that are not variants
so
for the text the main text schedule
active i'm going to press t
and i'm going to write schedule
activity
and i'm going to left align this and i'm
gonna basically make to say
i'm gonna move myself here and i'm gonna
make this a top header bold
and i'm gonna get you here yes
and i'm gonna make this autobit
and i am gonna definitely change this
color from black to dark blue so it
matches with our color palette
and then what i'm going to do is i am
gonna design this frame
so it looks like it will have 327 pixels
because it stretches
horizontally
and i'm going to fill it
and i'm going to flip it to our white
color
and i'm definitely going to add the drop
shadow because it's hard to see the
white it's 4 to 16 pixels
10 percent and yes
i definitely need border radius of 8
pixels which is what we usually have for
the rectangle elements
and that looks pretty good i think it
will be taller so maybe 128 pixels
yeah that is that might be too tall
maybe 1008
and we will figure it out but the first
things i want to do is i want to add the
adult texture so this is basically
the
user selecting how many adults how many
children how many people they will bring
for the activity is it just you and your
partner or is it just you
or do you have a kid with you so
i'm gonna make this also dark blue
and i'm gonna make it out of it as
well and
what i'm trying to gauge here is
let's zoom into the screen
and that looks actually pretty
okay i think we might need a double
like
no maybe not
maybe
yes
all right so what we can do now is we
can press r for rectangle
and this is probably is the hardest part
of this
of this video because we are creating an
element from scratch this probably has
48 pixels for height
maybe not 48 but 40.
yeah 48 might be a stretch
i'm looking and 48 looks big maybe we
thought with the border radius it might
look smaller but
now 48 is definitely back maybe 44
no maybe 40 is it 44 or 40 it's 40 yes
because 48 was big so 40 pixels
and
even with that one we probably want the
background to be blue
ish and okay so then we want our stepper
functionality minus m plus i'm gonna
press r again
and we might want these to be 32
by 32
and i probably want this to be eight
oops
i probably want the border radius to be
eight as well
whoa eight is too much maybe four
yeah
four is better and i want this blue to
be a bit darker maybe even 300 nope 300
is too much maybe 200 yes
i need 200 is pretty good
and i'm gonna drag this
and i'm gonna basically
take this one pixel down so it's four
four four
and take this one pixel to right so it's
four four four and at the center of it
will be our text
so yes to t
and let's write this zero
and i'm gonna have this to be bolded
actually
i'm going to have this to be bolded
i'm going to have the centered
and i'm going to have this autobit
and i'm going to check the distance it
has
and maybe here
it's seven to six so it's 259.5
and that is centered now i'm going to
check the vertical spacing here and i'm
going to zoom in to see that's three
that's four so it should actually have
one more pixel in the up
so it should probably be here
for centered
no sorry
my bad
it should be around here
okay
so
that
let's check our work so far
okay we need to get the icon
i get that
okay so
maybe let's check it
okay so we need our icons
so i'm gonna go to our icons on our
assets panel
and i realize we actually do not
have the minus four plus icon so
let's go to our icon set very quickly
and fetch those
so i'm going to icon set shift 2 to
shift
shift 2 to zoom in oh what did i do
okay so we are here
shift two
so i'm gonna right click plugins and i'm
gonna
basically check for feather icons
i'm gonna check for plus
and i'm checking for minus
okay so i think i got both of these
icons so one of them is in right now
i don't think the plus is in the icon
set but i think we can just by going
down here so i have to drag the plus one
okay so they are both in
so both of their colors should be dark
blue
and i'm gonna make you guys go here
and i'm gonna select both of them and
make them a component
oops
make them a component and that's pretty
good
and
oh they just okay my mistake
i have to make them okay figma doesn't
make you do a component for each so ctrl
alt k for this one
ctrl alt k for this one okay now it
works now we are good
so let's go back to our screen
click on the screen shift tool to zoom
in
and let's just add
from our assets panel our newly minted
icons
this
is the minus
and this is the plus
okay
those look pretty good let's make these
all white
and let's
basically also
make these guys have one pixel so i'm
gonna have to go back because we didn't
change their stroke yet
so i'm actually going back to the icon
set i know guys this is frustrating
this is my mistake yes so that's one
pixel
ah they are both going to be one pixel
and this is one pixel as well
okay now we are good i know we are good
enough
again click on the screen shift to zoom
in
okay
that looks better
so let's look at this is this
centered here
i'm gonna basically grab this and make
these two things an element so ctrl g to
group
and what i'm gonna do now is i'm gonna
basically center both of these elements
i'm gonna also do this for the plus side
and then i'm gonna click both of them
and center them
yes that looks pretty good
and then what i want to do is i want to
name this sd
yeah that part isn't useful i think we
duplicated something that was necessary
i'm going to name this background
and that looks to me pretty good
let's look at our example here i think
our steppers can be a bit smaller
but so here is the thing if we make it
smaller they will also be harder to tap
so this is really your decision if we
get them smaller now they will
aesthetically look better
but then being big enough also might
give the person a confidence to actually
try to tap because they are bigger now
32 pixels i think in the design there
are 24 there in the way i did it
but there is also benefits to having it
at the size
so i think i will just keep it at size
for the usability
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
design this by 12 pixel
and definitely like eight or nine
so i'm gonna zoom in here
yeah definitely 89 here
okay maybe 16 will be the way to go
but then you might realize for you to
solve this is a actually a good dilemma
so
so for you to actually
center design these elements which is
like the stepper
elements
oh
we haven't grouped those yet okay my bad
that's not the element
okay so let's first make this a group
shall we
with the background and this
is our stepper functionality
so we will make this a frame
and this is stepper
and let's check if everything moves with
it when we move it yes
okay so we want to center design these
two elements the adult and the
stepper functionality and let's copy
them and i'm going to show you a visual
problem
now what is and we have to grow this
size it's 128. so what is the visual
problem here now while the
figma is telling you the distance is
equal
between
the each row the problem your eye is
having is the vertical space between
adult to let's say children here
is a lot more than the stepper
functionality two and stepper
functionality one so it's 8 pixels this
is probably 30. and your eye is confused
because your eye is usually looking for
consistent spacing it's looking for one
type of spacing if it's 8 pixels
vertically it wants it to be 8 pixel on
the right vertically as well whereas on
the left we have a 30 pixel on the right
we have an 8 pixel well how do we solve
this what apple does is very smart in
their design is they add a horizontal
line
so the moment you add a horizontal line
your eye fixes on the lines and it just
checks the distance between line and the
top here and i'm going to show you
so this would be like
maybe
268 yeah maybe 2
72
and this would be a gray line
and both of these elements would be down
and so
maybe even a bit longer maybe
282 okay tonight so let's check the
distance here
so
yes maybe
so that's 327 pixels
so that's 20
okay
so that's maybe
18
or
24 24 so let's group these and make this
first row so that will actually make you
understand better so let's
group
and this is first row
and let's group this
let's frame this and this is the second
row
and now i'm going to show you
so now
what we can actually
discuss is this
okay so what's the distance between
these two elements gonna be
and
one thing we can do is we can even use
auto layout to actually
picking guests let's say
one thing we can do is we can actually
do auto layout to actually determine the
distance now so you are going to see
what i'm doing so
what's the
margins in the left right and
other men
other parts let's make them 16
here
16 here
16 here
and 16 here
and we want these to be left aligned
that's for sure and
one thing we can do here is this we can
actually pick the distance between each
item
and what we can pick is let's say 12
and
what i want to do now is to pick here
so it's actually if we pick it 16 if we
match it to the outer spacing
that might even work better so if we
were to do this
so now your top spacing and your element
spacing matches so that looks much more
unified the only thing this has to do is
we have that auto layout here too
so we can match them
so i'm going to add auto layout for this
sub children like the roles so that we
can actually horizontally center the
elements as well instead of being the
child being top alan i want them to be
middle aligned
and now that looks pretty good
i'm pretty
and takes the horizontal line
our eye actually
calculates the
vertical distance from this line to top
from this line to bottom
and
the only thing we might have is
no i think that looks pretty good i
think we might be a bit
we might have a bit more height here
but i think it looks pretty good i think
this is a bit more squishy yeah that's
136 pixels maybe we could have gotten
everything to be 12 pixels on the left
right
and other parts but i think this part
works
so i think we might keep it 144.
i think i like it
and let's get this to be
all right guys this is already getting
to be a long video in the next video i'm
gonna actually finish this screen the
second one and see in the next video
alright so let's finish the screen
so what else are we lacking
i think we are lacking alignment for
and we like are lacking spacing
so
one thing i'm going to do is
i am going to actually start with the
checkout
with 24 pixels which is r and i want to
add i can actually do worship four and
i'm going to add the layout grid as well
to this one so we can actually check
with check which items are aligned
our margins left and right to be 24
pixels and 16 here
and
so let's begin with our header here
and i'm gonna zoom
in a bit farther okay
that looks
pretty good now
maybe one more pixel
yes 22 does it does the job
and i wanna now
i want to get i think this element is
already aligned at 24 pixels
so that's good i want to get the drop
down to be aligned as well
yes
and then what i want to do is
it doesn't need to be that down
now the distance to be 24 pixel
and i want this to be 24 pixel as well
yes i want this to be 24 pixel as well
one pixel more down and i'm going to
hide the layout knob
ctrl shift 4 okay
so
i think that is our first version
now
one thing we might do is i think in our
drop down we haven't added the calendar
icon that i have maybe it might make
sense to actually edit because it helps
so
what i'm going to do is i am actually
going to our icon set to fetch it
and then i will add i will update the r
variant later
so i'm gonna go to
right click
plugins
and feather icons
and i can check calendar here
and boom
and i'm going to add this to our icon
set
so it's gonna be picked from left side
here all the thing to here
all right so now it's in our icon set
and i'm going to
basically make its color to be dark blue
and i am going to change its stroke
width to be one pixel
and then
i am actually gonna make this a
component
and before i make it a component this is
actually a bit big so i can i might want
to resize it so i'm gonna go
icon resizer
that is at most 16 pixel and yes that is
better
now i'm going to make this a component
and i'm going to zoom out
and i'm actually going to go to the drop
down here
okay so
we might actually wanna have it here
i'm gonna add it to all four variations
so i'm gonna go to assets
and i'm going to fetch it from here
and i'm gonna move this a bit
and i'm gonna get it here
and one thing you wanna do is you want
the emphasis to be less on the icon and
more on the text and one way to do that
while still keep consistencies while you
make the two elements have the same
color you can actually decrease the
opacity of the
let's say the icon in our case so what
you can do here is you can make this
eight percent and boom that already
makes it better
so what i'm checking here is
what's the left margin there that's four
so this should actually be eight eight
plus four is twelve
and
these actually can
maybe
difference is four pixels here and yes
that looks pretty good
yes i think i really like the look here
so i will just
copy
and i will
move everything basically so this is 36
so i'm gonna move this to be
36 as well i'm gonna
copy the
calendar and paste it here
and i'm gonna do the same for the other
so 36
i'm gonna do here 236
and i'm gonna paste it here
and i'm gonna paste it for this one as
well
and that looks perfect okay
so let's go
and
one thing we can do is we can already
realize because our variants are
components once we make a change to the
master element it auto updates itself
and it looks perfect
so
i think this screen is done maybe change
this color to dark blue
so what we can now do is we can work on
the second screen
and that is basically us actually
picking a value
so that is actually picking the number
of guests so this would be part two
copy
and scheduling part one
copy
and what we can do here is we can
actually but the only change we will do
between these two screens is make this
two
and voila
we are showing the interaction now
and that looks pretty good
now at the end of this tutorial we might
actually go back to change some of our
drop shadows in certain elements to give
them more emphasis but right now i want
to make things consistent this looks
pretty good
so let's do the screens
third and fourth
so these are the screens where we will
actually
design so i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
duplicate the schedule part two
and i'm gonna duplicate the schedule
part
no i'm not gonna duplicate this one i'm
gonna make this go to part three and all
i'm gonna do is probably just add
the
date picker drop down
and that looks pretty good so
well
one thing we are actually realizing here
is this
where
we are actually going overboard here so
so let's actually get this well the
coordinates for this one is not correct
so it should actually be 10 pixels lower
maybe
11. yes so that is the coordinates and
this should be also lower
around here
and
this should be roughly 16 so
412
because this part of this element so it
should not be just 24 pixels
maybe even
12
would work yes
so
now
now so this is how it looks like and
right now it is not packed
and
one thing you might think of it is is
there a problem with it opening over the
checkout button i do not think so
because our checkout is already disabled
so that is pretty okay
one thing we might do is we might
actually move everything a bit up
or we can also let's see how many
so it should end around here
if you really want to but that is
probably not needed
so i really like
if it overlays i don't think there's a
problem with overlaps i don't think
there's a problem what i'm trying to
think is
what would happen once you picked it and
you can actually go to checkout and then
if you are trying to press the checkout
button but you press here and it's all a
mess okay so we need to decrease the
height of this and we need to decrease
our spacing around
a bit so
one thing we can do is let's go back
here
and this was 24 pixels as well what is
the distance between each element
here is 24 so so far we have 24 pixels
so let's tank
maybe we can get this to be up a bit so
this is like 44 this is 66 so we can
actually yeah i think that is the
mistake so
everything here has to go
up so
one two
three yes so now
yes so if you trick check here now our
back button matches
and i'm gonna do the same for this
screen
i'm gonna hold shift
one two
one two then i'm gonna so what i'm doing
is the moment i hold the shift it
actually shifts 10 pixels instead of one
and for 22 pixels i have to do that
twice then take my hand off [ __ ] and go
twice again for 22 pixels
and i'm gonna do this for here as well
i'm gonna actually not do it i'm gonna
copy again
and i'm gonna add in my assets
here
and
that should be pretty good
yes that is a lot better and these
should also be going down
so
yes so that is a bit better so another
place that we can actually change is we
can decrease the margins here
and decrease the spacing around here
so what would happen if we did
12
and with this 12 as well
that still looks okay
and yeah that still looks okay so we can
actually get this up
one two three four that should be 24 yes
okay
so you are seeing a lot of copying here
because
one mistake
like we have made is our spacing well i
made this our my spacing didn't work so
we are trying just a bit of stuff here
and i'm gonna delete this again
drag this and now it should work
probably
let's see
yes now it works
yeah
okay
yeah and
that is okay
that looks pretty good to me
and then what we can do is we are gonna
rename this
this is part three copy and we are gonna
drag a new version of this oh wait
i think
so this should be two because we copied
stuff we forgot to change these says two
because they already made the choice of
the adult at the point two
in three they are gonna they open the
date and then the four which we are
gonna create right now they have
selected the date
so this will be selected
the moment they press done then we are
okay to go yes and this is the part four
all right let's do the fifth screen so
i'm gonna
drag this one
and i'm gonna write this as five copy
and the thing the difference once we
make a choice in here and we say done
while we picked the date the user has
picked the date they have not picked
the time of the day that they are
actually gonna do the activity in so we
have to give them the option that they
will also have to pick the time
so
what we can do is we can go back in our
screens and
basically copy this horizontal filter
process
which we have
and we can actually paste it here
and what we will do is we will just
change the
we will just first we will make
everything to be
unpicked
and what we will do is we will just
change the time so
it's it will be like
zero eight
zero zero am
and this would be
zero nine
zero zero am
and then we might jump to let's say
eleven eleven zero zero am
because we are just showing the
available times
and then this would be
thirteen 000 pm
and so i'm gonna go to layers
and
one thing we might do is we might add an
auto layout for this one
and we might get this to be 12.
yeah i think that actually looks better
and we probably want to center this
right for this one
so i'm going to zoom out a bit i'm going
to look here
and i think i am going to get this to be
off
nope the other way
5151 that works and this should be 4
pixel above
for 12 pixels and yes that looks better
and then
now that part of the screen is done then
what we can do is we are gonna design
the sixth screen
so i'm gonna drag this one
which is the last screen for our
schedule
and then we will have one option picked
let's pick this one
and then what we will have is this
disabled button has to be also active
and boom
that looks pretty good actually
i'm gonna vertically align these and yes
those that was our scheduling feature
and in the next video we will do the
last two variants
so that we can actually design design
the last screen the review screen for
the checkout so we only have one screen
left to design
and to actually do that screen we need
two more variants the first one is what
i would like to call medium cards varian
which is this one where it is a bit
different it's the activity one so only
four activities and
what it is is that it doesn't have a
label for like that we had so i have to
like zoom out a bit here
maybe
maybe pick one here
i think around this and zoom in here so
if you look at the activities here
each of these activities have this label
that signals what it is but for the
medium cards that we use in the checkout
they don't so we will have to create a
new variant for this one
and the second variant we will do
for this screen is the small avatar
images here these very small ones unlike
our large avatar images
which we use for the attendees these
won't have a name attached to them
like as in writing
let's get those going so i'm gonna
actually zoom out here
and i'm gonna go to our image cards here
what i'm gonna do is i am going to
create a new frame
i'm gonna name it small
image
maybe medium image card
medium image card
it's not that small
so and i'm going to give this let's say
a bit of 156 pixels i'm going to give it
a fill
and i'm going to give it eight pixels
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
actually add the images and i know these
medium cards will only be used for the
activities like eating hiking or biking
it won't be for the cities because you
can never check out the city so what i
will do is
i will actually
remove the fill color right click
plugins
and i am actually gonna go to unsplash
and i'm gonna type eating
and i'm gonna pick the same activities
there and i'm gonna add the same overlay
which is 25 percent if i recall let's
quickly check
and let's quickly check and it is 75 and
i will check the
height and bit of it actually
so i am checking the height and width
and its width is 212 to 148 so it's
actually bigger than ours so
maybe these are the medium ones
i misnamed them card
and this is going to be a large image
card so
so this is
2
12
to 148 pixels
i'm actually going to make this a
component by pressing ctrl alt k
shortcut
and then i'm going to add variance
and first i'm going to set the property
and the property will be
basically activity
and the first one is going to be
eating
and for the second one we are going to
change its image
we will look for biking here
and pick it and let's name it
biking
and let's add one more
and let's actually go for the hiking
all right i'm gonna search for hiking
and this one is weather yes
so those are the same hiking
and boom so now that we have it
what we can do is that
we will actually zoom out and we are
gonna go to the avatars so
let's zoom out a bit more
and i am looking for where my avatar
cards are
maybe even if it's more and i'm checking
trick and checking
and
[Music]
so in the okay there you guys are okay
there at the bottom
i did not see these
okay
these are our normal so let me just grab
this
here and avatar images so if you have a
large avatar you want to create a small
avatar so to do that i am gonna press f
and i'm gonna zoom in here
i'm gonna
do shift two
to zoom in
and i am basically going to make this
maybe 36 to 36 and i will give it a
border radius of 18 pixels to make it a
circle
and i'm going to give it a bottom line
there
and for the sake of this discussion
i think i will change the background of
it i to this so we can see things better
okay so what i'm going to now do is that
i will actually get images for this one
as well so this will be named small
avatar and this is maybe even like we
can be a bit smaller maybe 32 pixels
yeah
maybe 32 and i'm gonna actually find an
image for this so plugins
and i'm going to use the plugin user
profile
that will let me generate a random one
and that is
not good let's do another one let's do
one that actually looks like a profile
shot
okay that is doable so what i'm going to
do now is i'm going to make this a
component ctrl alt k
and i'm going to add a variant and our
property will be name just like our
large avatar
and this one let's say is
lucy
and for this one i am gonna do the same
i'm gonna do user profile
insert random photo
and this one is let's say
helen and i'm gonna go plus here
and what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go
random again and i'm gonna do this three
to five times right oops wrong plugin my
bad
i'm gonna right click plugins user
profile
and let's see
and that is
let's say jane
and then i'm gonna click again
and this is the last one
let's get a man here
and that can be
matte
okay
all right so
let's begin designing our last screen to
begin i'm gonna press f
so i'm gonna press f i'm gonna pick my
iphone 13 mini
and i'm gonna make write this as
review copy
and
the first thing we are going to do is we
are gonna get our variants that we
already designed
so we are going to begin with the bottom
navigation
and we know the coordinate is 760
and x is zero
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
looking for the status bar so i'm going
to move myself to the right
i'm going to get the status bar here
i'm going to make this 0. i'm going to
make the y 0 as well
and its colors over the dark blue maybe
i should be around here yes
then what i'm going to do is i am
actually going to get our
t
for the
elements and for the text and i'm going
to write checkout
i'm going to auto
with the element and then what i'm going
to do is i'm going to make this bold 34
pixels and i'm going to get this dark
blue
and then i'm going to get my
maybe image cards and in here i want the
large image card
definitely and i want this to begin at
24 for x
and then what i will do i will press t
again and i probably want this to be
biking
then i'm going to zoom in a bit and i'm
going to press t
for the activity name
right biking
i'm gonna basically move myself back i'm
gonna make this out of it
and i'm gonna make this sub header
so that is pretty good
and then what i want to do is i want to
get my location icon
so i'm looking for my location icon
right here
yep that's my location icon i'm gonna
get text
for the place london
ontario
and i want this to be dark blue as well
this one to be dark blue as well
and i want this to be body regular
and i want this to be autobit yes and
definitely regular here
and one thing you can realize is it is
not enough this has to be a bit smaller
so what we can do is maybe we can go
maybe span element here
that would work better yes that does
work better
and i'm gonna align those later then i
want my
small avatar images
so for that i am gonna go amateur images
and i'm gonna get a small one
and what i'm going to do is
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
zoom in with shift 2.
0
and i am gonna duplicate this
by dragging it
and duplicate another one and another
one and i'm going to make sure that all
of these small avatar ones are
centered
and now
what we want is basically them being on
top of each other so the one that is
most on top of each other in the
logically meaning in the design also
usually should be the most on top so
that's the goal so this one would be
let's say lucy
and this one let's say make this helen
at
helen is definitely
so lucy is going to be the first one
helen is going to be the second one
and
let's say jane is the third one
and
yep jane is the third one and this one
can be met
okay
so this is the most top
this is going to be here
this one is going to be the third yes
so now then what i will do is i will
just take all of these
holding shifts so they would come 10
pixels back
maybe around there
so let's check the distance between
those two elements that's 13 to 13
so maybe
one more
and 12 yes
so we are looking for 12 here i'm going
shift
with my down key here
i'm gonna check again yes that is
correct
again just 10 pixels at a time
oh i'm holding
i'm holding caps guys you didn't tell me
how dare you okay i was making me say
you should hold ship not caps
okay i'm i was wondering why this is
taking too long man so i'm gonna
print these as
avatars
small avatars
yes
so that is correct and i'm gonna
then move to here
i want the color of this to be dark blue
and i want you guys to be
centered here
and maybe
let's fix the text
and maybe move the text to withholding
shift a bit to the there
and
i'm gonna count the distance so that is
like five pixels here
so maybe six seven
so six
uh
i'm doing x
okay
so i know five pixel is here one pixel
is there that's six we are looking for
two here so it will make to eight
for our icons i think that's pretty good
we are to center it again and we are
going to frame these as
location
that is pretty good
and then the initial part is done
then we will do the activity details
so let's press t
your activity
details
and these are going to be sub headers
right so i'm going to my type system
subheader and i'm going to delete left
alignment and i'm going to do it out of
it
perfect okay
then i know i will get pricing but let's
first finish the your activity details
and to do this with the right alignment
we probably want to have a layout grid
with columns and again it's 24 pixels
left and right 16 in the
distance and that's pretty good
so
we already understand that we might need
to come back a bit but yes
then
we will add date
so i'm gonna just press here
this is gonna be date
and then guests
yes okay so date and guests
and all of both of these will not be a
sub header now but will actually be
bodybutt bold
and then we are going to add the
small
tertiary buttons of edit
so let's add those two from our
variants
let's find our buttons and then get the
small buttons here and we definitely
want the tertiary option
and yes so let's put these guys around
here
and let's name these edits
perfect
and let's look at here
yes that looks pretty good
so what i'm gonna look for now
so edit option is there
we are missing two body texts
so
t here
is for
the date june
22
and first i think it's june 22
june 22
june 18 22.
let's check the date that we selected
this 18 june 22 okay yes
so this is correct and i'm going to make
this body regular and i'm going to make
this
this way yes
and then i'm going to go for guests here
and that is going to be two adults
zero children
that's okay yeah
so
to align things better what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna zoom in a bit
yes and i'm on a windows machine so my
magic pad is very very
like very sensitive so what i'm going to
do now is i'm going to make this a line
better
yes so that's the 24 pixel that looks
pretty good
and i'm gonna
edit this to the end
so they would match
that's perfect and
these colors should be dark blue
and everything literally should be dark
blue never black
so
yes
okay so then this is gonna go here
and
what i'm really trying to do here is i'm
gonna check the spacing it should
probably be 24 up
[Music]
oh 20 okay that's not bad so maybe 24 24
for us
so i'm gonna do
listen like this should be roughly 14
so i'm gonna zoom in i'm looking for 16
pixel total
so four pixel there seven pixel maybe
nine
yes so that is the distance and
this should be roughly 12 total that's
four five yes that is correct that
should be the distance and i am actually
gonna get this up
and the distance between drew 9 guests
should be roughly 16 because they
actually belong to a different group so
the
distance between data and activity
should be the same as the guests and
date which should be 16 so
i'm zooming in
there's three pixels here
that's four seven so that should be
roughly nine so
two three four
yes
and it will be a bit to the left
there we go and this one is also just a
bit maybe not
and this one is as well i just wanted to
touch there yes
and that's pretty good so far okay
so now what i want is i want to patch
this one as well
and i want this to be five based on just
like here literally i'm just
copying my distances
and that looks pretty
good let's look at it from here and that
looks pretty good
now this has to be aligned
so i'm checking here where it goes maybe
a bit up
no
and i wanted to see how it's
basically how it
looks from here i'm gonna turn off the
yes i'm gonna turn off there and
i'm gonna press shift r to actually have
a ruler present to see the middle point
and maybe one pixel up
so maybe around
here yes
i think that's the way to go
and
then what i'm going to do is i am going
to duplicate this
and i am basically gonna go down a bit
and i am gonna have it around here
and i'm gonna do my ruler again to check
if it's
aligned centerwise on the baseline no
it's not
so maybe
one two three four five
okay
baseline again which is the middle of e
and that looks pretty good yes i'm okay
with that i'm gonna press shift ctrl
shift
ctrl 4
the right alignment is correct so we can
actually frame these now so
i like our spacing so i'm going to
select every element
so i can make them all a gigantic frame
ctrl alt g and i'm gonna name this
activity details
so i can do the spacing of the whole
element easier
because i want this whole group to be 24
pixel
here and this one is probably just going
to be 24
here so that should be like
should be four five
yep
four
eight so that should be like 16
so
maybe
one
yes
roughly here is 24 for it
and i am gonna get this to up as well
yep
and
i really don't watch 18 pixels maybe 16
horizontally and
each of these elements can have 16
pixels
here
so that's 10
so maybe one two three four five six
and
i'm checking for the vertical alignment
with my shift r ruler tool
and
so this should be a bit to the right
that's good
and this should the smaller beta images
should definitely come up
and let's see their distance
so that's ten so six plus four here
that's ten
so maybe six down
two three four five
six
and that looks pretty good
the only part is it looks too spaced out
so
maybe it should all be 12 pixels so
maybe
one two three four
and let's do
one two three four
yeah that actually might look better
that looks to my eye better that's
roughly
16 pixels yes so let's check
4
7
that's 16 maybe even more right
three four and i'm gonna do the same
maybe this should be 164
and that looks better yes that's much
less spacing
and i'm going to frame these as well so
gonna frame these three elements
ctrl alt g
and activity
t
basically
review
and then what i'm going to do is
i'm going to do the pricing
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
press t
and i am gonna write this as pricing we
are almost there
it's looking good i'm gonna make this
dark blue and you have done this before
this is gonna be our sub header so i'm
gonna
make this go out of it as well and then
what i'm going to do is i am just going
to copy the contents of this text
my bad
so i'm going to go here ctrl c
i need
new text and i'm going to control v
and i'm going to make this a normal
regular
and i'm going to also give this a auto
width
and make its color to be dark blue there
we go and i'm just going to duplicate it
for the taxes so
i'm going to press alt with shift so
that the alignment keeps
not getting disturbed and i'm going to
write
450
for texas
so i'm gonna go here and write
450
for taxes
shift 2 to go back to zoom mode and
that's
77 okay so then we will have a total
there
okay so then what we will have is we
will press alt
shift
and this is going to be our total
and this one is actually bold
and i'm going to create another text
here i'm going to duplicate this
and i'm going to write as 77
77 and
yep
that's already out of it i am gonna
shift this to the right edge
and i am gonna
duplicate this one again
holding shift with alt
and i'm gonna write
4.5 and i'm gonna
get it to the right alignment
so what i'm looking for what am i
missing is the final total number here
then i will have to frame everything and
my total is missing total cad so
c8d here
so i'm holding my shift and i'm
pressing down and there we go and that
is if my mat is correct 81 50
and i'm gonna
yeah shift it here
and that's pretty good
so what i'm going to do now is i'm going
to group all these elements
i'm going to frame them ctrl g
and this is your pricing
and one thing i can do is
and this could be a cool spacing i'm
gonna frame these as well
this is the
fee
and this is going to be
taxes
and this one will be
total
what this will let me now do
is that
now if i ever add an auto layout for the
vertical i want this to be
left and i want this to be maybe 12
pixel
or let's go maybe
yeah 12 works pretty good actually 12
pixel works here and i want this to be
bold as well
right here yes
so that works and i'm gonna get rid of
the
layout grid now
and i'm gonna make the color of this to
be white
these white as well
yes i think we have to go back and
recolor these because these are pure
white
it's a detail i just called let's go
here
i'm gonna come back just a moment guys
okay this is why you should check your
colors beforehand
okay that should be good
so
but final thing we need is actually the
paved frame
with the edit option for the card and we
have a pre-selected card
and we also need a
large button at the below so let's do
that first
let's get this one it is disabled so
it's an active
it's primary and it is basically
pay
yes
so make a payment this would be the best
one
payments
and i think
this should be primer i don't know why
this is disabled actually
this should not be disabled at all so
let's make this active
and that should be
24
yes
that's better and then we can add the
card
so i'm gonna press
this has to go up a bit
yeah
maybe even more up here roughly yes
24 pixels and then i'm going to press t
for writing
pay with
so pay vet
and this is going to be a sub header
and it's gonna be autobit and it's not
gonna be black
yes
everything
nothing is black yes
okay
so then we are going to create our card
our card is 327 pixels
press r
i'm gonna get it turned 327 and 64
is probably gonna have at least eight
pixels on the side it might have even
more
but eight pixels blue but it's gonna
have our dark blue color
and it's gonna have our name the user's
name the
expiry date the type of card it is
and then it will have the last four
digits of the card
and so for that we are gonna have t
jason malta
and i think for this one we are okay to
do it with
regular span element that's okay
and then we will need the the expiry
date so i'm gonna just drag it here
zero seven twenty five i'm gonna make
this out of it
and then i'm gonna get our visa icon
from our assets from our icon set my
profile here
and let's get this visa icon
and let's give it a color of
maybe this blue now maybe it's 200
100 might work yes that looks pretty
good
and then i want these circles so i think
they are roughly three or four pixels
so i'm just gonna go in and do them so
roughly 12 circles
for the whole
credit card so
i'm gonna press all
and i'm gonna make this
four
maybe five is even better yeah i'm okay
with five so i'm gonna then drag here
and then i can do is i'm gonna
hold shift to drag with the same
distance
and
that looks pretty good so
i'm gonna now hold these first four
i'm gonna hold the
choose these first four make them
have the white color
and then i'm gonna drag this whole group
and i'm gonna do it again
and
not again my bad
last one we don't need it
and then i think they are not spaced
equally yet so what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to say
distribute vertically that's awesome
and then i'm going to have the text
last four digits which can be 3406
and it really should be a span element
because this should be very small
and yeah
that looks pretty good i'm gonna zoom
out a bit
yes that looks pretty good to me
this has to be at the edge so i'm
holding shift when i'm moving it to the
right
and what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to align the
this one so
i
want 12 pixels up and left
so
i'm zooming in
that's one pixel so this should be
roughly 11.
and it is two pixels so this one should
be
the
y should be roughly
here so 10 plus 2 is 12.
that looks pretty good now i'm going to
align it my bad now i'm going to pick
the
visa and i'm gonna
go to x i'm gonna align it here
i want these two elements to be
aligned to the right well so
maybe one more pixel
there we go
and i'm gonna check here
that's 9 12 yes that works
that works
and i'm gonna then pick all the ellipses
the number
and we'll group these
control g
card number
and i'm gonna click on the text here
maybe one pixel up to be centered
yes there
and that's
pretty good actually
i am pretty pleased let's check the
vertical and horizontal spacing here
and what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to copy the y from here so this is
6 21. so
so this is like 621
and to look at its left alignment of 12
pixels i'm just gonna
press alt that's 16. so
that's 12. yes that looks pretty good
because is no left spacing in the phone
so it is correct so we are going to
align these as well
yes
and let's get these guys to the bottom
as well
so that's nine
maybe around here because we are gorging
with the text here
yes
that should be pretty good
so i'm taking a look
and
i'm gonna group all of i'm gonna make a
frame out of all of these ctrl g
this is credit card and let's see if we
can move everything here
after the background didn't come in so
let's move this here
background has to be at the bottom
that's good
and let's see
oh
yeah
i don't think we took every element
there
so
yeah the card number didn't come in so
let's move the card number in this well
okay
so let's enlarge in but our frame is a
bit off and
right now my shortcut doesn't work
so i'm just going to check the distance
here
and that can be between these two
elements
that is 12 we probably
wanted to be in total 16
that's four that is good that is
excellent actually
we want here 18 24 that actually works
so it actually works i'm pretty happy
with it
so there you go guys that is your screen
at the end and
yeah
that is the whole tutorial
i think it looks pretty good there might
be some spacing issues here and here but
if you have stuck a lot stuck
along with me so far thank you for
watching this tutorial
i hope you enjoyed it
and if you really like the free code cam
channel and like my tutorial please you
know
click and subscribe you can learn a lot
on this channel for developing or ux
design perspectives and
have a fantastic day